thank
you good morning everybody Welcome to
Edna I'm opening the public hearing on
House Bill for 1413 and I call
Representative
Greg good morning Madam chairwoman and
committee it's nice to see you all today
um for the record I'm representative
Alicia Greg I represent nashille award 7
and I'm here today to talk about um bill
for House Bill
1413 and this is a bill that in kind of
looking at wording and how we're
licensing and stuff um with our
different sections uh we came across
this particular section that has some
outdated language but not only that it's
duplicative and so I'm going to let um
OPC is here I'm going to let them
explain why it's duplicative even more
but what this does is just kind of
cleans this up so it's less confusing as
we go about our licensing process um and
that's I think that she would be better
qualified to explain that more all right
thank you
um director
Courtney thank you madam chair um
members of the committee Lindsay
Courtney executive director oplc and
wish to thank representative Greg for
bringing this forward so essentially
what this bill does is it would repeal
the current provision in the statute
that um provides for I'm going to give
you the exact term um
unlicensed practice under supervision
agreement um so that's 3:30 a22 so as
you may recall several years ago this
legislative body um establish license
types additional license types under the
board of mental health practice several
of those license types are called the
conditional lure and the testimony that
we heard was essentially that we needed
to establish lure in order to provide an
easier pathway for reimbursement so as
it stands we currently have two Pathways
for these people we have the unlicensed
um um person who is operating under an
approved supervision agreement under
330a colon 22 and then you have folks
that are licensed operating under
supervision agreement but are subject to
the jurisdiction of the board and this
um this dichotomy presents um some
challenges I think administratively to
the office but also I think what we've
observed is the challenge with respect
to the unlicensed part is that the board
doesn't have excuse me they don't have
jurisdiction over the individuals who
are actually practicing under
supervision so if there is an issue um
and we've had this happen where the
person being supervised uh commits
misconduct the board doesn't have that
jurisdiction and cannot discipline and
otherwise notify the license the public
that there could be a a problem um
actually the burden is on the leny
providing the supervision whereas under
the other model the uh the person who is
licensed has a conditional license is
subject to the jurisdiction of the board
so essentially this bill would repeal
that second pathway um and provide for
one pathway uh to obtain your
LCSW um which is uh a conditional
license for a certain period of time
under supervision that's approved by the
board happy to answer any
questions thank you I have a question
how many people have conditional
licenses versus are practicing without
licenses or don't you know the latter
number so I don't know the total number
of people who have approved supervision
agreements yes um I think you may recall
that the rules establishing the
conditional licenses were the rules that
issue um that that the governor and
others brought forward um at an
executive council meeting and jail car
considered those rules in December
postpone them and they will be heard by
jail car I think on Friday
we've resolved um the stakeholder
concerns so I I have every reason to
think that they will move move forward
but we we haven't actually issued
conditional
licenses um I suspect that by the time
if this legislation were to pass uh a
lot of people who currently have
approved supervis supervision agreements
would seek conditional licenses because
again it provides that benefit of
allowing for reimbursement
opportunities so how many people have
approved supervisory agreements that I
would have to get back to you on
representative thank you it would be it
would be good to know does anyone okay
representative grota and then
laus thank you um Miss
Courtney I just want to make sure that I
understand this I'm sorry did you say
representative leus after you okay thank
you um so are we saying then there will
not be a path for unlicensed people
requiring supervision is that what we're
saying yes if were to uh adopt this then
correct okay represent leus thank you um
so right now are there any requirements
for someone for any anything for the
person who is going to work under the
supervis visory agreement and um if so
how do those compare to the requirements
for someone to get a conditional license
I'm trying to figure out if if there's
somebody who's currently working under
the uh such you know supervisory
agreement uh who could not um apply at
least you know without doing something
further for conditional license I think
there are members of the board here and
I would defer to them on the specifics
but I think the intent when adopting or
or I'm sorry um working on the rules to
adop the rules adopting the conditional
lure that the intent was to keep the
requirements the
same okay thank
you
uh representative Schmidt and then uh
Simon thank you madam chair so I I heard
your earlier answer to representative
Le's question the chair's question about
the numbers so even if you don't have
the exact number at the moment and
you're going to get get it for us you
have some idea whether it's a lot or
very few or what if you have any
idea I don't want to I don't want to
guess representative so I can certainly
email the committee that that number by
the end of the day today that would be
great thank you all right represent
Simon thank you madam chair and thank
you director for taking my question um
you had mentioned that uh one of the
problems with the supervisory agreement
is that there's no direct oversight of
the board uh is that correct yes however
looking at the statute they do have
direct supervision over the
licensed um practitioner who's
overseeing um the supervised cand
correct correct so I'm just I just want
to make sure I understand correctly as
all so don't they technically have
supervision over that person through the
licensed
individual yes well so they do have
jurisdiction over the ly providing
supervision the issue is that sometimes
instances of misconduct are not due to a
lack of supervision or appropriate
supervision and so you can't always take
action against the leny providing
supervision and then you're left with no
mechanism to notify the public that
there was this finding of this this
issue of concern thank you for that
clarification appreciate it other
questions thank you very much thank you
for your
time Melbourne
Moran there here we go hi thank you for
having me Madam chair my name is Mel ban
Jr I'm a licensed independent clinical
social worker I'm also a former State
Rep representing formerly of War s and
I'm also um Alderman at large for New
Hampshire's greatest city the city of
NASA um but here today I'm um
representing my company waterlust
therapeutic services we provide
counseling to over 1,000 individuals in
Southern New Hampshire and about 30% of
those um individuals are Medicaid uh or
Medicare patients uh we're about a two
plus million dollar company or so um I'm
here to speak to you about um this
supervision contract which is uh wholly
unfair to the private um uh sector of
mental health counseling and I'm glad to
see that this legislation was brought
forth to eliminate it some of you may
not know but these supervision
agreements do not apply to um the mental
health centers or nonprofits or
institutions they're exempt from having
a supervision contract uh this only
applies to the for-profit industry uh if
there is a person who has a master's
degree in social work who wants to
practice Psychotherapy at greater
natural mental health care they can
start on day one if they graduate um
from Graduate School uh if I want them
to work for me I have to get approval
from the board through a supervision
contract because otherwise they're not
permitted to conduct Psychotherapy in
the state of New Hampshire that is one
of the reasons I'm here to ask that you
uh eliminate this and as the board has
already saw a fit uh create the
conditional lenses of um
lcswc lcmhc CC so that person who's
applying exact same requirements um if
you're following the rules of the board
of mental health that someone would have
for the um supervision agreement is
already in place that they would just
whoever has it now my understanding from
reading the rules as proposed and I
believe they're going to be similar as
there's someone else from the board here
that can uh State um more detailed facts
that those folks would just migrate to
the conditional lure and not have an
interruption of the service that they're
providing to their um
their clients one major issue with the
supervision contracts as they stand my I
have about 35 employees maybe half of
which are under supervision agreements
and half are licensed I have licens
providers who are in their 80s if that
person suddenly becomes ill or dies the
person that they're supervising cannot
see their hundreds of patients I'm I'm
going to say four clinicians because
that's I think the board caps at four
supervises per per lense e we have to
stop providing treatment because they
are no longer under a supervision
agreement because that person's uh
incapacitated their supervisor that does
not apply someone at the mental health
center someone at uh uh Harbor care or
another nonprofit institution and that's
uh in one of the rsas of 330 um so I'm
here to you to ask that you repeal this
language because it's whol unfair to
small businesses that are providing
Healthcare and quite frankly now that
private insurances are allowing uh
pre-licensed professionals uh to Bill
through their licensed super supervisor
uh it is very uncompetitive and I cannot
see anywhere in the state of New
Hampshire to have a business be
uncompetitive with a nonprofit it it is
blows my mind and I'm a Democrat uh very
funny story my colleague from um uh Ward
one he's a alderman with me Tyler Goa
Republican he's down stairs uh
advocating for the firefighters and I'm
up here fighting for capitalism very big
day today um but I'm I'm saying that
these contracts are not fair to the
private uh mental health industry
there's a mechanism coming forth to
allow conditional licensers uh that
gives board oversight of someone who's
not fully licensed and it eliminates
this competitive advantage that
nonprofits have against the Private
Industry who in my opinion provide
better care and I'm doing with my money
not state
money okay well thank you I'm glad
you're in favor of
capitalism is there anyone that has
representative Manti thank you madam
chair so if I um understand you
correctly this is
creating currently what we have in the
system is two tier for mental health
providers am I correct yeah there's a a
tier for nonprofits and a tier for for
uh the Private Industry nonprofits folks
they can still get um a contract they
don't need it I worked in nonprofits
before this I can tell you many people
did not get it they go to try to get
their license and they oh I've been
supervised for two years oh there's no
board contract on file you can't but why
was I practicing for two years because
that your company's exempt so there's
also a lot of confusion around how
someone can get licensed uh because of
this contract that exists the way it is
follow
thank you so how does this help or
enhance the acute shortage we have for
mental health providers in the state and
uh how does this
allow to get more people to get into
medical I mean mental
health that's an excellent question uh
if this was eliminated the day after
someone has conferred a graduate degree
that meets the qualification ations uh
of the board to render Psychotherapy
while being supervised they could do
that uh day one instead of waiting up to
I think it's 120 days which one of I
when I first opened my business um in
NASA in 2020 my second office I had to
wait 120 days for the board of mental
health to approve a contract before one
of my employees could start to work for
me doesn't make sense so people will be
able to work and provide healthare yes
okay represent Blas um this is for you
is somebody from the board signed up to
speak or if not um if they could answer
some
questions is there somebody from the
board of mental health practice here yes
uh we'll we'll we'll talk we'll ask you
to put in a card and we have some
questions for you the board of mental
health has not had a chance to meet uh
and vote to authorize anyone to speak
they wanted to be here for this they
cared deeply and
passionately the board thank you I would
I understand that you'd haven't taken a
vote and you don't have a formal support
or opposed position but you should be
able to give us some information I hope
I can I can try okay thank you please we
would love to have
that okay any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony all right Diane
Castrucci hi my name is Diane
Castrucci I am a licensed substance use
counselor and I'm here representing
myself because I'm not currently
licensed by the board that this vote is
about um however I am opposed to it
based on what clinical supervision is
supposed to be about so
um RSA 330
CA talks about the type of supervision
and that it needs to be convenient
between the person who's supervised and
the person who is providing the
supervision and the types of protections
that need to be in place for appropriate
supervision the way it's written it's
100% aligned with the LC board it is um
important for there to be a supervisor
in place when someone is a candidate
towards a credential because the
supervision that is provided is about
helping that person learn how to do what
they're trying to do it helps protect
the public by
um guiding them in appropriate ways of
delivering Services it helps them deal
with issues so that like if I'm the
counselor and I'm brand new and I'm just
just trying to learn I don't try to
treat them like my dad you know because
my dad needed Services kind of situation
it helps them separate their own
personal stuff out of the services that
they're trying to provide to their
client um just as one example of of a
very small amount of what clinical
supervision does it clinical supervision
also helps them um with on the job
training about how to be a proper Su uh
counselor and without that clinical
supervision there's just regular
administrative supervision from an
agency and the clinical super because of
clinical supervision being set up you're
able to talk about confidential
information specifically about a client
in a different way than you would with a
general overall administrative
supervisor that is the end of my
testimony thank you could you answer a
question or two I can try Okay um I
understand that you're testifying that
the conditions set up for supervision
here are correct is it I agree with them
yes I like how they're set up I like
section
330a and how it describes clinical
supervision I believe you don't you
don't take away something that's not
broken okay I the question is are you in
support of allowing UNL licens people to
enter into these
agreements because that's that's what
the sponsor says the difference is
and I don't see that piece in the
legislation okay thank
you
representative so in the um legislation
it repeals all of RSA -
a-22 so is
there a a part of the RSA that we could
keep and eliminate some I'm wondering if
there's just perhaps
a part of RSA 22 that doesn't
apply well the I'm trying to because it
repeats the whole I'm looking it up as
we speak and I looked at this I I agree
uh president br I think the D what we
would want to do is instead of saying a
candidate for license mental health
licenser say person with a conditional
license would be the way to do
it I just Madam chair do we not do we
not we don't know how I thought there
were no conditional licenses issued at
this time no but they're set up in
statute ah and the rules are are almost
done
mhm
okay
so that's the question is do you are you
in support of unlicensed people being
supervised or just people who would be
uh on track for for uh the
license I believe anyone unlicensed
should be
supervised um
in the lak world once someone has um
their credential if it is a bachelor's
level or below they still need
supervision whereas someone who is
Master's level or
greater can work with peer collaboration
with their peers but there is still some
mechanism that exists that has them
communicating with each other about
proper care of
clients thank you very much I think
followup followup thank you so um I
understand what part of 322a so the part
of 322a that says that supervision of a
candidate for mental health lure shall
include the following so basically it it
defines what that relationship is
between the like the person doing the
supervision and the person being
supervised and perhaps
we may want to take a look at that
because it actually formalizes that
relationship and it makes it
rather
strict and so maybe it's can be it for
example right they have to assume the
responsibility of the candidate which
you understand right and then if they
are if they cease to supervise that
person they need to be notified in
writing I'm just wondering if some of
this should be done in rules as opposed
to in statute so if we does this make
sense where where I'm heading I don't
know if well I think we're it's not as
quick and easy as we thought okay well
definitely not as quick and easy as we
thought exactly okay but thank you for
that information it's for sure valuable
any other
questions okay thank and uh ma'am from
the
board
right now uh provisional license he has
the supervision set
up correct you're talking about the
conditional license conditional sorry
okay certainly uh it goes in tandem with
the conditional license and uh sorry I'm
not able to see you but I am still
talking to you um and requires that um
that the supervisor be properly vetted
for supervision as well as uh the
candidate having their um goals in place
for what they are hoping to get out of
supervision um and then the board can
make sure that those lineup um with uh
their their licenser uh license type and
um and that they meet the high standard
um these these folks are going to be
diagnosing individuals and so this this
level of supervision is incredibly
important follow up Madam chair um I'm
aware of clinical Fellowship year in
speech language pathology and Audiology
so as soon as you graduate you have to
do nine months or a year of clinical
Fellowship year to get your license to
practice independently is is provisional
license similar to that in mental
health it sounds analogus to me yes um
it it's a it's a two-year requirement
however
um rather than than nine months but yes
to prepare them for diagnosing and other
such okay thank you other question Madam
chair is this going to go to
subcommittee I believe it it should yes
if it does it's going to the licensing
subcommittee representative lacus thank
you so I'm looking at um the statute
that this would repeal about the
supervision um it says the supervision
of a candidate for mental health
licensure my question is what are the
requirements to be a candidate for
mental health licensure I was just
glancing at that and I don't see any it
means it elsewhere in statute maybe or
rules or
that's a great question um I
am looking at the definitions
and uh in the statute there is not a
definition for candidate for mental
health licenser I had that same question
with the board when I first joined them
um I would recommend that they Define it
and maybe they have in Rule and I could
look that up for you um follow up follow
up yes um okay so I guess this is going
to the licensing subcommittee if you
could be available or someone else who
could answer these questions could be
available um what I'm trying to get at
um is you know what what does it take to
be a candidate for mental health
licensure and how does that compare to
someone who is eligible to apply for a
conditional license I'm trying to see if
in effect this is a direct replacement
except for the board having Authority
and not having to uh have a u u
supervisory agreement or will there be a
supervisory agreement for uh cial
license those are the kind of of
questions I hope you someone can answer
for the subcommittee sure well well the
first thing is that um the candidate for
mental health licensure is for one
license type for the licensed clinical
mental health counselor whereas the
conditional license is for all of the
license types uh it's not just for
Mental Health Counselors but for S
licens to practice independently but
they are working towards license
insurance so they must have supervision
when they're not properly licensed thank
you thank you madam chair okay Madam
chair I see the prime sponsor trying
yeah eager to get back and clarify
something yes thank you uh thank you and
I'm glad you'll have your support for
the
subcommittee representative Greg you
have a uh some more information for
us thank you madam chairman uh
chairwoman and committee I should have
had more faith in myself on my first
bill to explain this a little bit better
and now I uh learning curves so thank
you you for um giving me this
opportunity once again I'm
representative Alicia Greg I represent
Nashville award 7 so in looking at this
my initial conversation was actually
around the language um which specifies
and legal so it it talks about how the
supervisor must be um both
professionally and legally responsible
for their candidate which is interesting
if you say in legally responsible within
the workplace this particular language
just says and legally responsible
I mean it's hard enough if you have an
over 18-year-old in your house to stay
legally responsible for that person so
you think about this and how this
complicates somebody wanting to be a
supervisor knowing this so in looking at
this statute statute this was actually
pretty common language back in the early
1980s um when they had this as far as
social work goes they have this an legal
was in there if you look at the history
of this it slowly Fades off uh other
other statutes have replaced those
particular lens or statutes this one
stayed so when I when I called oplc and
said you know would you be in favor of
taking off in legal because we seem they
actually said it was duplicative and
that was the biggest problem now what is
it duplicative of um and they stated
that it was duplicate duplicative of
330a
18d so at that point I looked at that
and I said well that's social work so
conditional license for social work so
you know I I kind of saw okay I can see
where where part of this is duplicative
because it's all kind of integrated but
then I think what we're doing is this
also refers back to
330a which is mental health practice
section so by repealing this particular
um statute that has an older language
that's not used in many other cases
anymore what we're doing is we're going
to leave that the regulation we're not
saying nobody should be supervised but
we're going to leave the regulation of
the supervision agreement to the board
which is kicking back to um uh 330a so I
actually have pronouns of each of these
if you guys would like to have them
tangible and kind of look at them um
side by side that always helps me but
that's it's not that we're um wanting to
get away with this big super it's that
we're saying this particular because of
the older language because it's
duplicative it actually um works against
you know being able to provide
supervisor that uh that clearcut what's
going to happen when they are
so thank you you're welome we'll this
will be going to subcommittee to sweat
up sweat the details great um so if you
could give that those papers to
representative La abely thank you so
much for the extra time I appreciate it
all right any other
questions all right is there anyone else
who wishes to testify on House Bill for
1413 all right seeing none I will close
the public hearing we will open the
hearing at 10 next hearing at
10:45 it sounds like there's like that
exemption for
nonprofits I don't see that
anywhere needed for you go
right
welcome
back representative
roachford thank you madam chair uh
members of the committee I uh appreciate
the time you've given me today to
introduce
hb12 um this is I I sent around some
testimony last night uh via email that
you should have received and I submitted
a printed copy to the clerk but this
bill is
uh many bills we see here um we vote on
and and even even introduce that really
don't have a whole lot of impact on
ourselves individually uh HB 1112 does
have an impact on myself uh if if passed
and implemented I will fully be um
expected to comply with this as I'm a
licensed pharmacist in the state of New
Hampshire
uh currently on the Board of Pharmacy
and um the Board of Pharmacy is under
the rule as you know is oplc uh 1112
really
um really started I started opening my
eyes onto the idea of human
trafficking in 2016 and that really
started back in
2007 when uh my I went on a mission trip
in southern Mexico and it was a remote
Town literally in the middle of nowhere
uh we were going into Villages that were
on dirt roads that were you know never
never seen a whole lot of traffic um
delivering we delivered Healthcare and
medical services to these folks uh I
went back in 2016 and what had happened
from 2007 to 2016 was dramatic uh these
little towns now the little roads were
were Caravans were passing in front of
these uh these houses um people from
clearly all over the world were were
headed north with a lot lot of
possessions uh many of them didn't speak
most none of them spoke
English most of them didn't speak even
Spanish uh and certainly not the the the
local dialect that we were in so we had
an opportunity to visually see what was
happening going going on down there as
we have seen over the last three or four
years that is massively exploded to
something that we can't even comprehend
even north of um The Notches where I'm
from I grew up in Coos County the
Canadian border was always in our
backyard uh and even now we're seeing
crossings that we've never seen before
uh my neighbor in Littleton is a border
patrol agent he says every day they're
catch they're getting people that are
that are migrating and um you know we
all know why they're migrating for the
most part they're coming here because
United States is the best country in the
world uh it's a we have freedoms here
that are uh un un un unseen in other
parts of the the world opportunities
that are unseen in parts of the world
but we wonder when we see all these
people how many how many are coming here
against their will or how many people
signed up for something that uh uh they
thought they were getting only to
realize that they were being um shuffled
moved purchased uh uh trafficked and
that's really where this is about HB
1112 is about human trafficking and it's
about the fact that there are people in
this country in this state that are here
against their will that are here because
they didn't understand what they signed
up for they're here for profit for
gratification uh for for whatever it is
but I ask you members of the committee
here um when how many of you have ever
been to a
pharmacy how many have ever been to a
physician's office how many have ever
been to an emergency room the reality is
people will go to seek medical care
whether they're here legally or whether
they're here undocumented Ed and the
purpose of the HB 1112 is just an
opportunity uh for education of our
healthc care providers uh our health
care providers in our communities in our
states whether it be Physicians nurses
pharmacists dentists we will come in
contact with people that are are
trafficked and HB 1112 one of the things
it does not do it doesn't add any
additional education to these folks uh
it doesn't add any additional charges
fees price cost to to to the licensed
Professionals in the state but what it
does do it allows oplc as a part of the
annual continuing education actually
it's biannual now continuing education
process of their required required
credits that they have to receive which
we all do um one hour of of that b
annual uh um education has to be in
human trafficking and the idea is really
based on the program that came out of
Florida and Florida when we renew our
licenses down in Florida we take an hour
of human trafficking education it just
talks about awareness
education what to do what to do about it
how to recognize it um and uh and if
suspected who to report it to um you
know I I've included all kinds of data
and and and and dialogue and um
statistics in the package here uh and
you're welcome to to look at it but one
of the things that I just want to
emphasize is that this is not new this
concept of um awareness to certain
topics is not new especially human
trafficking uh according to the
University of Michigan Connecticut
Florida Louisiana Michigan New Jersey
New York Ohio Texas and
Washington have um requirements for
their health care providers to be
educated on human trafficking some of
those states are southern states some of
them are northern states some of them
are are places where we wouldn't
wouldn't expect it but the reality is
that it's here uh there's a human United
States Department of Health and Human
Services has a human trafficking hotline
and since its Inception it's received
571 signals if you will um um in a in a
variety of of of formats so that's
hotline calls text messages online
reports whatnot and in those 571 signals
uh the human trafficking hotline has
identified 112 cases of human
trafficking
366 were identified that's right here in
New Hampshire so sobering when you think
about this is an underground activity
this is an activity that that people
don't talk about it's secret it's it's
the people are silenced when they talk
about it so just in New Hampshire 366 V
victims of an intentionally silenced uh
um practice are going on right right
here
um I think when I decided to submit this
bill really what what you know I said I
I I've thought about it and and and
begin to comprehend it and really start
thinking about how much is out there
that we don't see when have we gone to a
restaurant and had that whole staff turn
over uh with new people and I know that
I've been to several of them and
overnight you know what what's the
what's the story behind that it could be
innocuous uh it might not be um but the
the the the issue that kind of drove at
home for me was over the summer when we
had a New Hampshire nurse who was
working in Haiti uh as a missionary and
she was kidnapped and many people
speculate that she was kidnapped for the
purpose of human trafficking and um you
know I think that you know to to pretend
that it's not here uh is
shortsighted um this is a bill that is
it's it it targets the individuals in
the state that will have a high touch
with this um and again it's not adding
any additional education requirements or
or or or or fees that they have to pay
it's part of the uh the normal process
of recredentialing in the state of New
Hampshire
um I'm going to leave it here with you
um and I'm happy to answer questions I
do have to know I'm literally currently
presiding over a Board of Pharmacy
meeting across the street so I'm happy
to take a couple of questions and I've
got to get back to to to my meeting
representative leus does have a question
sure thank you um I'm just trying to
reconcile you know uh what I heard you
say and what's in the bill and you said
that there's uh something about one hour
you said there was no additional
training requirements and and no
additional cost but this thing requires
at least two hours of continuing
education in this area so that doesn't
seem to Jive and uh and that's got to be
paid for somehow I mean you there's
going to be maybe some change the cost
to that or something so I don't
understand your testimony sure
absolutely so every health professional
in in in New Hampshire has to in order
as a part of recredentialing every year
has to do a certain number of hours
every every every two years in my case
as a pharmacist I have to do 30 hours of
um continuing education every other year
to continue to get my to get my license
uh so this is not adding an additional
two hours but of those 30 hours of the
hours that profession are required to to
to to to do in order to to get their
license two of them per two per B any
one per year uh has to be in this topic
and it's not an additional fee in that
they're going to have to pay for they're
paying for these hours anyway uh if we
don't have this bill it's not they're
not paying anything additional they're
going to be paying we don't have this
they'll pay for something else um so
it's not adding any additional burden on
the uh uh as far as a cost or or or hour
requirement followup followup
um well presumably in the case of
pharmacist the 30 hours was uh hopefully
being consumed uh teaching something of
some value so you're going to take two
hours away from that for this and you
know what's going to be lost as part of
that I have to wonder yeah I mean I mean
30 hours is a lot of hours I mean just
just in in in in again speaking from
from personal experience if you're going
through the motions if you will if
you're if you're if you're attending
professional uh continued education in
the normal course of your career you're
going to get far more than that um you
know already you know at the end of last
year uh I'm already ahead of what I
personally would would normally get um
and you know there's no specification on
what those as it is now there's no
specifications of what those hours could
be so conceivably if you found 30 uh
hours
of um
you know HIV counseling which is good
right I mean I'm not going to say but
you could load up your entire 30 hours
with something that may or may not be
you know pertaining to your to your
specialty all right thank you yeah all
right thank you rent froda yes I think
this might help um because I'm a little
bit confused in the in your continuing
hours is it not part of the um your
rules for lure the 30 hours
are cover these specific subjects or is
it and that you have like a menu and you
can pick two from a and three from B is
that what is it what your is this can
you help us on that absolutely so when
when when a board defines what the hours
have to be in so for instance I can
speak for myself my daughter's a nurse I
can speak for her um you know my
brother's a dentist we can you know what
what the rules what the rules say is
they have specific spefically for for
going to give you the example in
Pharmacy they have to
be Pharmacy uses ACP approved credit
hours so APC ACP is the national
credentialing Agency for crediting so if
I want to put a course on I want people
to be to get credit for it I have to run
it through this ACP so they have to be
hours 30 hours every other year uh ACP
approved credit hours so that could be
anything I mean it's a if if when I get
my license and I have to renew it I
could get you know in when you go I mean
the providers of acpe credit hours are
are wide and they're varied I mean
literally hundreds if not thousands of
courses that you can take that are ACP
accredited and I can take um find those
courses in in in and there are many many
because so many states are doing this
there are a lot of acpe accredited
courses in human trafficking so it's not
going to be hard to find one of these
courses uh for that those folks okay
that was my follow-up question so thanks
so much yeah and you know I'm going to
add you know if if if we were the if we
were the uh the Trailblazers in this you
know if if we were the first ones out of
the gate then that would quite frankly
probably impose a hardship um but
because there are so many other states
doing it there are a lot of many of the
uh credit Prov providers are providing
credits geared towards this requirement
representative Shu thank you madam chair
that that basically answered my question
if there were people provided to do the
education okay other questions
representative Simon thank you madam
chair I know you're in a hurry um no
you've mentioned that several other
states are have already implemented this
are there measurable successes that you
can report in that area that you know of
where implementing it has helped to
um pinpoint traffic trafficking yeah you
know first there's two ansers I'm gonna
answer that in two ways one it's a it's
um fairly new in that uh only within the
last five or six years that that we've
seen this implementation of that uh I
think if there was probably a state that
could quantify it I don't have those
numbers in front of me um and I'm I'm
I'm surmising that Florida Florida has
really been out front with with a lot of
this um and in fact I believe there's a
conference just this afternoon at the
the holiday in talking about a Florida
based uh human
trafficking program that that is is
geared towards hotel in the hotel
industry uh you know I I I don't have
numbers that I can put on on hand I
would speculate if there are it would be
either the University of Michigan or the
State of Florida that would have
those thank you other questions
represent VY thank you madam chair a
quick one are you um through this bill
are you putting it such that just like
the abuse and neglect are to be reported
this also has to be a reporting uh event
for any uh pharmacist yes thank you for
the question and you know this is just
an education component of this bill um
this is when I when I put this together
I with the director of oplc and I asked
how we could do this um and and and and
she suggested you know this would be the
the format that we would go but it's
again it's just the education I don't
want to deputize every health care
provider in mandate that you know you
you get into adding that because I think
that opens a can of worms um but it's
the idea of recognizing it and and
understanding if you see it this is how
you would be it this this bill does not
have a requirement for reporting but it
certainly um you know having gone
through a lot of these trainings uh
there is a you know they often do detail
on how you would report something like
this but there is no duty to report in
this
Bill thank you okay thank you very much
for your testimony good luck with your
board great thank
you Ben Bradley
getting ready ref
information it was
emailed and here are some hard copies if
you want one only one and there's one
hard copy here for the
file
good morning Madam chair um members of
the committee my name is Ben Bradley I'm
the vice president state government
relations with the New Hampshire
Hospital Association representing all 26
of New Hampshire's hospitals as well as
all specialty hospitals throughout New
Hampshire uh while we appreciate the
focus of HB 1112 and the importance of
training in human trafficking each
professional board that regulates health
professionals already has the statutory
authority to require specific training
as they see
fit although there may be other worthy
training topics for health professionals
on topics such as reporting of elderly
abuse or communicable disease this would
be the only education requirement
mandated by the legislature historically
except for opioid prescribing training
requirements that were repealed last
year the legislature had has left
decisions about mandated training to the
professional boards with oversight of
health professionals we believe these
decisions are best suited for each
professional board to determine and
therefore the hospital Association is
respectfully unable to support this bill
um thank you for the opportunity to
provide our comments and I'm happy to
take your
questions
thank you representative G thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question my question is do you think
this is a topic that the boards are
aware enough of to even be on their
radar um I haven't solicited each board
but you did just hear from the a member
of uh the pharmacy board so um it's
attuned to him um uh and and so I I
can't comment on everybody but um I
would suggest that they review the
training of their licenses
routinely represent leus thank you I I
can't comment on pharmacies but I can't
remember being in any medical facility
that doesn't have some notices up about
reporting if you feel threatened at home
or other things like that so my question
is um along with that are hospitals and
other medical facilities uh doing some
you know what what if any training goes
along with those notices for the staff
already certainly I I think hospitals
take this issue very seriously um again
I haven't solicited all our hospitals to
find out what kind of training they
provide in human trafficking um I'm
really just hoping to speak to the bill
and and what it does which is um would
have the legislature mandate specific
training on human trafficking um I'm
happy to get additional information for
you um but we do take this issue very
seriously disrespectfully uh believe
that it should be at the board level for
determining what should be required
follow yeah I'd appreciate if you could
do it and that it does apply to the bill
because if you know if there is
something going on already um about this
I'm not sure that we're requiring some
of the currently existed training would
be the best way to go understood okay
representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair uh are you
still uh working with one with Douglas
as you have in the past or are you now
just with New Hampshire Hospital
Association uh so I'm employed by the
New Hampshire Hospital Association and
Wentworth Douglas hospital is a member
of our association yeah okay thank
you other questions thank you for your
testimony thank you madam
chair Dan
Cuchi hi my name is Diane Cuchi I am the
the executive director of the New
Hampshire alcohol and drug abuse
Counselors Association which runs the
New Hampshire training institute on
addictive
disorders we are the
largest
um through State contracts funded to
provide professional development
training for people who work in um
mental health and substance
use I would be opposed to this
bill
because when you have a requirement that
people have to do every two
years it tends to be something that is
broad-based like the ones that we
currently have which are ethics people
are required to get ethics every two
years they're supposed to um get suicide
prevention training every two
years the increase of suicide training
was done through a legislative process
so there is a precedent out there to
create training imposed by the
legislature because that's how several
boards Incorporated The Suicide
Prevention the topic of human
trafficking we have offered at the
training institute off and
on
at least for at least six
years and when this the state got
funding for a state opioid response the
sore
funding a lot of human trafficking was
happening related to
opiates that people that were um being
trafficked would be forced to become
addicted to opiates so that they could
be managed and
controlled by the opit so you had to do
certain things and then you would then
you would get your fix and then you know
so there was a lot of human trafficking
happening so the mental health and
substance use provider communities have
been getting training in in human
trafficking for a while I could see it
as a valuable thing for initial lure so
that people start off knowing about it
but as a a requirement to get more
training about it every two years it
runs into to a problem where it's the
same training every time so that there
are
um less trainings available for people
to go to I'm not aware of it being
offered Prof you know a lot in other
states New Hampshire is stronger when it
comes to the professional development
education than Maine or Vermont um
Massachusetts very strong but in terms
of the number of trainings provided it
would be difficult if it is
mandated for mental health providers
then it's logical to think
that the the state would support
Workforce Development and they would
need to
um provide funding for that type of
education especially if it's being
offered at the level that it would take
to reach all of the providers which
would be several a year um so although
it's not a direct cost there would
definitely be an indirect cost providers
we do have to get substance use
education I mean
um education for renewal in in the um
the mental health substance use space
space it's 40 to 48 Hours a year and
representative lus is correct that if we
are doing the um the human trafficking
education chances are something else is
not going to be what we're going to get
the education
in so I would say yes that human
trafficking education is important um
with the way things are happening with
um
so many people coming into the country
undocumented that chances are there's a
lot more human trafficking than we have
any concept
of
and I I think it's an important thing to
have I'm just not sure that two hours
every two years for every health care
provider is the way to do
it thank you for your testimony are
there any questions representative gold
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question and sor sorry to ask
so many questions today um my question
is I like what you said about um a
requirement for licensing initially
upfront as opposed to the ongoing
requirement do you think that's
something that can be done through
licensing rather than through
legislative action I think it can
absolutely be done through
administrative
rule
um the value when you do something
through lure versus through
administrative rule is that lure can
make it happen
faster
um and so I guess that's a decision that
needs to be made at a different level
for I think now
that oplc manages so much more of what
the boards are doing that it'll be
easier
to change Rule and have it broadly
applied so that the changes that were
made in the last legislative session um
could actually
benefit making this happen at a
different rate than what it would have
if those things didn't happen thank
you or sh
it okay fair enough other
questions thank you very much for your
testimony thank you Douglas AER
hat
good morning dougo Soler how of thec uh
I don't have the office doesn't take a
position on this I really came up
because I have more clarifying questions
I think there's some ambiguity around
some of the language I think first off
one of those is whether whether the two
hours is part of say a 30h hour
requirement or if that's above and
beyond I'm not sure it's clear from this
language and then the second piece I
have a question about is the definition
of audit uh if that is a separate
process or if that's just part of the
renewal process if it's part of the
renewal process just making a
requirement um would make this audit
language somewhat redundant and then
based on the testimony I just heard I do
want to clarify that oplc would not be
able to mandate that the boards undergo
this in rule the boards would still be
able to set their own criteria for lure
uh so to your question representative if
you wanted to apply to all the boards
legislation may be proper if you wanted
to give the boards the ability to choose
rule may be the appropriate rout but
that's more just
Technical and that's that's all I wanted
to say today all right we do have a
question representative ship thank thank
you madam chair um I will ask my
question now I I was looking at this and
considering if uh oplc thinks the boards
would be amenable to just changing the
language to say that um there should be
an update uh of continuing education on
this
topic I'm not sure I could answer that
question without talking to the boards
first because I can't speak on behalf of
the different professional boards who
would probably also vary from one board
to the
next yes representative Manti thank you
madam chair uh do you know of any boards
under
OPC that has this requirement education
of identifying human trafficking as we
speak today I'm going to say no but
there's also 57 separate boards and I'm
not necessarily familiar with the
individual education requirements within
the particular
boards uh I'm interested in your comment
on the audit because
representative berford did not mention
that and what I don't know what shall
audit compliance does that mean 1% 10%
50% well I think that's my question here
as well and then also um to that point
if you make it part of the CE renewal
process will always check two hours of
continuing education I'm not sure there
would need to be a separate audit it
would just be part of the renewal
process okay but it it doesn't Define do
you currently audit continuing education
and if so
how it varies it varies thank you I'm
not
surprised all right any other
questions representative lacus
one more question on that so um when you
say a check on it I know it varies but I
mean is there a tendency just to verify
that they file the paperwork that they
say they had the class do you somehow go
back to whoever off the class make sure
they were really there or something like
that it does vary I mean there certain
things you can do you can upload uh
continuing education certificates
there's certain reporting requirements
but it does uh vary from board to board
and there are some boards I can't think
of them off the top of my head because
I'm not involved in the audit side but
that do require certain mandates every
now and then a little deeper dive for
for the continuing education component
okay um followup yeah followup um yeah I
mean I wasn't sure what that meant and
um I guess it it gives 541 a Ru making
so you'd have to if this passed you'd
have to go through that process to
Define just what an audit me anti spells
but it's not specified here is that that
the case I I think so all right thank
you represent
Vera I just want to help um with it with
this um with this
bill um Mr a how you might remember and
correct me if I'm wrong that last we we
move the um responsibility of monitoring
the continuing education process uh from
the Board of Medicine to oplc
and we had to have a a small
Amendment at the end of the we all might
remember this at the end of the January
4th or third I can't remember house
session where we um had to have an
amendment removing the responsibility of
that auditing from the Board of Medicine
so that's an example of an audit of a is
that
right yes it would be an example okay
any other questions all right thank you
very much for your
testimony does anyone else wish to
testify on House Bill
1112 okay in that case I'm closing the
public hearing and we
have 10 10 minutes before the next on
house to
uh
de
welcome back I'm opening the hearing on
House Bill 1410 and I call the co the
absence of the spon the prime sponsor I
call Representative
leus uh thank you madam chair uh little
history on this um this was among a
number of bills that uh were requested
by the governor it was put together as
were the others in uh consultation with
executive director Courtney of oplc and
I was asked to uh to run it through the
process um executive director Courtney
had assured me she'd be here for this
hearing I'm not seeing her on uh but um
so I can go give a quick overview on
this um but I'm not uh prepared to go
through all the details at this time
um so the uh I'll skip actually part one
and go through the other ones first most
I mean a lot of this is similar things
that we've done with um you know with
other licensing boards especially last
year the um um part two on the nurse
Practice Act Board of
Nursing
um you know a good part of this is
changing the uh the members MIP of the
nursing board um the number of members
who's on it it adds uh you know APNs or
RNs instead of just RNs um in a number
of places and there's changes to uh the
requirements for being on the board here
similar to what was done for other
boards
um some language
changes the uh third part third section
which is starts on page two line 23 gets
into the powers and duties of the board
and again this is largely um going along
with the changes we've had of moving
certain responsibilities from the boards
to
oplc
um that's I think that's pretty much
what's in that
one
um okay and similarly on the next on uh
part four and Page
Three um is makes some changes to the uh
Ru making Authority and it moves um some
of it from the board to oplc because
responsibility for some issuing licenses
and other things were were moved as well
so all of that is is pretty similar to
what we've been doing uh similarly part
five related to criminal background
checks follows um you know other changes
we
made and part six changes um the LNA
from uh being licensed to
registration um and part
seven make some other changes to the
nursing license um what I'd like to do
there's there's uh two other people here
who can get into the de well first of
all get into the more of the reasons
behind this and um
that's miss jurius you know if she could
speak on that and then um director
Courtney for the details um of the bill
from oplc and that's that's all I
have thank
you Miss
jurius if you if you could speak on the
policy intention of this
Bill yes thank you madam chair and good
morning everybody
um for the record de jurus from the
governor's office um Governor s's policy
director um so the intention behind this
bill you'll be seeing a few before you I
believe um I think a number of them
might be going to subcommittee I may
have heard from the chair uh similar to
bill is this bill is in fact going to
set a commit okay great so I'd be happy
to be here to be a resource for that as
well um this is a continuation of a lot
of the policy initiatives that we kind
of started um last year as you'll recall
there was a hefty chunk of the budget um
the governor's proposal that was
regulatory reform specific to licensing
boards so this is along the same lines
of that idea which is trying to um
consolidate boards where appropriate to
rightsize them to ensure that regulation
is still appropriate with the Board of
Nursing um but getting the membership to
a more manageable amount while still
making sure that appropriate parties are
represented um additionally um some of
the repeals would be for um additional
burdensome red tape or fees for lenses
or people who are working in the state
um to try to reduce barriers to entering
the workforce or continuing in that
regard um so specifically I know the LNA
license is a is a Hot Topic and I'm sure
something we will continue to discuss um
but part of the consideration is there's
already a federal requirement that they
are on a registry that's
maintained and the condition for lure is
that they complete the cours workk to be
on that registry and then pay the state
of fee to to do their job and so our
thought is could we eliminate that extra
fee and just allow them to work without
that and there's still the oversight
from the federal registry so that would
be the policy consideration there um I'm
happy to answer any other specifics but
does that give you a good sense of where
we're coming
from representative pra thank you thank
you Miss Jewish most of these um the
components of this bill were House Bill
too
correct I believe that is the case and
uh if I may I'll just add I think some
of the cleanup language some of the
striketh through in this is a result of
when there was reconciling as we know
there were a number of different bills
and I think as they were signed
effective dates were different there
might have been some language that was
removed reinserted um that this
committee would have pass so I believe
some of it the bulk of the text is kind
of clean up from that piece of it when
you were clarifying ining and the
results from the
2022 330 study committee which the bill
from 23 the number is escaping me at
this point but I think a lot of those
changes kind of were reverted back so
this is kind of writing that piece of it
follow up follow up so last year in
House Bill
655 yes which was also included in House
Bill 2 we considered that bill and made
a lot of changes to oplc based on that
um what information do you have if any
that those changes have come to fruition
and there's been a benefit
scene um I'm happy to answer that in
part I would defer I believe you'll hear
from executive director Courtney she
could speak to specifics about um the
pace at which they are able to award the
licenses due to the transfer of that
Authority um I don't have those figures
in front of me but I do know that the
turnaround time for licensing those
specific um professions has been cut
down drastically so between the
completion of application and the
awarding of the license um has been much
quicker I think the roll out for other
things such as disciplinary actions
where they um they can investigate
immediately that timeline I think will
need to be played out over the longer
course I'm not sure we've seen direct
results but again I'll defer to her on
those specific metrics thank you
yep other questions thank you very much
and I trust you'll be able to support
the subcommittee
happy
too okay um I think I will ask director
Courtney to give us some details so we
know what questions to
ask thank you madam chair Lindsay
courney executive director office of
professional life insurance
certification and um please is my my
apologies for the delay in my arrival I
was with the Senate um testifying on
another matter so essentially I just
wanted to explain what this bill does
practically um and how we would
administer this bill if it were passed
um so two things are easy to explain it
would essentially eliminate the
requirement um to register medical
technicians and the requirement to
license Medical Imaging and
radiation technologist which is not an
actual license type so you should know
that there are a number over 10
modalities that have their separate
license types but it's essentially all
of the Imaging licenses that fall under
the Advisory Board um for that
jurisdiction um so then with respect to
lnas what this does is it eliminates The
Lure component um for the licensed
nursing assistance while allowing um
those individuals to retain the title so
essentially providing title protection
and I wanted to explain how that works
practically with the office right now so
there is a a federal requirement um in
the cfrs that all states have uh a
mechanism to approve programs that will
educate um individuals they use the term
nurse aid but other states use certified
nursing assistance nursing assistance
licensed nursing assistance um that we
educate with a certain minimum number of
hours in the Federal Regulations I
believe it's 75 we requ 100 and that um
as as soon as and that they pass a
competency evaluation and it requires
that as soon as the person completes
that process that we automatically
register them with the state within 30
days and what this means is there's no
application process um and because uh
the state primarily Department of Health
and Human Services receives money from
the federal government for maintaining
this registry um we are not allowed to
charge people to be on the registry we
also have a lenser component which comes
into place after somebody is registered
so the way it works is you complete the
course you take your competency
evaluation we get the information from
the testing facility we put the
applicant into our licensing system and
it's called Uh not licensed registry
only and then at some point if they
choose to do so they apply with their
office they pay a 30 $ 5 lure fee they
pay a $28 fee toward the professionals
health program they undergo a criminal
history record check and we issue a
license two years later they have to um
their required registry and then two
years from the date of their license
renew their license I will say that it
is somewhat confusing for applicants
this duplicative process um but I also
wanted to point out the key differences
between our current process and and what
is proposed so the differences are that
under what is proposed in the bill um
the lnas would not be required to
undergo a criminal history records check
by the office um there are some
requirements for long-term care
facilities and for hospitals that
require criminal history records checks
but that would be conducted by the
employer and it not be conducted by the
licensing Authority so that's a key
difference the other key difference is
that um under the federal regulations
the employer is required to provide a uh
attribute expenses for licensing lnas to
the registry as opposed to the license
um and we get a DI Minimus amount from
DHHS and I think that they uh would be
required to give us substantially more
um under the bill as proposed but again
that's just a selfish uh ask from the
office uh not speaking to the policy
considerations so those are the the
primary differences I'd be happy to
answer any questions that you may
have I have uh one
question I from study committee I was on
some years ago the scope of practice for
an LNA primarily on nursing homes rather
than hospitals and other places that
lnas work in New Hampshire yeah so I
will say that the authority that the
federal government has to impose lure
requirements and we are always I say we
uh oplc in is always protective of the
state's authority to to regulate
occupations as opposed to the federal
government but the federal government's
authority to impose this um these
registration requirements has to do with
our acceptance of their funding and I
mean dhs's acceptance of their funding
the State's acceptance of the funding
and so it certainly comes through the
long-term care process and our
regulation of long-term care facilities
that said when you look at the federal
registry requ requirements we are
required to register anybody who has
completed this course it doesn't even
matter if they work in long-term care it
doesn't matter if they work period the
fact that they are eligible and they
completed this course we are required to
register them and so by virtue of that
it applies to
everyone thank you does anyone yes
representative G and then man py thank
you madam chair and thank you director
for taking my
question my question is um and you may
or may not be able to answer that there
may be other people here who can answer
just let me know my question is uh I'm
concerned about the criminal background
checks and the lack thereof um that this
could you know are we creating a hole
that people could slip through and so my
specific question is around um home
health care do you know if that's if the
background checks are done by
requirement by those um
agencies I don't know I also don't know
that everybody providing Home Health
Care is an LNA and I do think that there
that's an element um that that's a
potential issue um but I don't know for
certain I would say that DH a has
imposed on the on the individuals that
they I'm sorry on the facilities they
regulate there are certain requirements
for criminal history records checks I
would also say that the accrediting
bodies uh typically which are private
typically um do have certain um
requirements but the state standards for
vetting them are are are
unique nice Qui thank you represent
beny thank you madam chair thank you uh
for taking my question so from the cost
shifting
perspective this bill would shift the
cost
from the
licy to the agency or D HHS or other
bigger
organizations especially for with the
LNA am I correct yes you're correct um
and so right now the Board of Nursing is
is is not meeting its expenses in large
part because we charge lnas so little
$35 when the average cost of license is
over 150 and obviously that's because um
there's a capacity um concern there and
um so certainly that would shift the
cost you know another way to resolve the
issue is to just not charge a fee for
lnas um you know I know in the past the
board hasn't hasn't
um hasn't supported that um but that's
another way to um to address that
issue thank
you thank you I'm
um your question your comment about the
Board of Nursing not meeting an
expenses what does that mean because do
you not have a
um will you not granted a $5
million over you know hold over so that
the money that you have an extra could
be used
to yeah so I think those are two
different issues so every board is
required to cover their 100% of their
expenses and I think um representative
you may recall that the oplc has had
rule making Authority regarding fees for
a long time but there have been
conflicts in the law that have really
precluded us from moving that forward um
both statutory and and Regulatory we've
recently eliminated those
conflicts um but for years the
established fees you had some boards
that were bringing in you know 200% and
then other boards that were bringing in
40% and so yes we had a lapse but I
would say it's not it's not because um
we had a lapse because certain boards
were bringing in way more than they
should and it was an essentially an
unconstitutional tax so we have enough
funding to operate the office but what
I'm saying is not all boards are meeting
their 100% of their expenses and for the
board it's been a really big challenge
because you can't raise you can't raise
LNA fees to $150 you just can't do it um
they don't get paid enough um and so the
board has opted to have their license
fees structured in a way that the RNs
and aprns are essentially subsidizing
the lnas but it's still um not
sufficient taking into consideration
inflation and everything else follow up
follow up so you run the boards as a
cost
center do I run the boards no it's
statutory representative that we are
required that the boards uh cover their
fully cover their costs if um you know I
think there's an opportunity for the
legislature to consider from a policy
standpoint whether they do want
subsidization I would think that that
would have to come from the general fund
and not from other boards because you
get into the issue of taxing um other
licensed professionals but this was this
was a statutory scheme created by the
legislature not the office apologies I
me oplc not you personally I understand
yes yes um in the oplc reports for the
last several years you can see that some
boards are overcharged and some are
under
charged and I will say we had a budget
I'm sorry
representative we had a budget
information session with the boards I
think it was last night I can't even
recall maybe the night before um in
preparation for FY 26 and 27 and um we
are going to um work in tandem with them
on the budget as well as uh adopting new
rules regarding fees to really level set
um but these are some really tough
conversations that we have to have
particularly for um the licensed
professions that um don't don't earn
enough thank you other questions
representative
Brown uh thank you madam chair uh good
morning director thanks for taking my
question good morning representative C
can you uh for me put in a simple
framework why this is
necessary following up kind of on the
governor's representative so I can't
speak to the governor's um initiative
but what I can say is practically on the
elen piece it it definitely would reduce
uh administrative burden it would it
would streamline The Lure
process um if it were me I would I would
say to the feds you need to update your
EGS because they haven't been updated
since the 70s and I think that's part of
the problem um but I think the process
is somewhat cumbersome for those trying
those people trying to navigate that
said um and you'll grapple with this
there's certainly some policy
considerations as I've outlined for you
to consider and then on the other piece
I think um it's certainly just an ex
extension of um some of the efforts last
session um which were intended to look
at um the board's um or I'm sorry the
licensed professions that may not be
necessary to protect the public if
there's another means of doing
so question represent Simon thank you
madam chair thank you director for
taking my question um still just trying
to make sure that I have all my
information correct on uh the nursing
board covering its own expenses so if we
were not to do the proposal before us um
we have a short fall of of essentially
$115 per LNA um from the nursing board
presently you're saying you're stop
gapping that by overcharging rnas and
other professionals to kind of balance
it which doesn't seem correct either
so if we don't do something like this
aren't we basically putting lnas in the
position of having to statutorily
speaking if we're going to do it
correctly they should be paying $150
which doesn't seem fair in its own right
but am I correct in that yes I think
what
I and I haven't thought this fully
through but I think if this were not to
pass my recommendation to the board
would be to fully eliminate the fee all
together so we could have a better sense
of um what it costs in order to Main and
basically merge the two and what it
costs to maintain an LNA license and a
registration and I would try to Bill HHS
to recoup some of his costs I don't know
how successful that would be but my
position is that essentially we are not
getting the funding um that is owed to
us follow up um so you had also
mentioned that the funding that could
potentially come from the federal side
of things if we were to change would be
significant what would that look like do
you have any idea what additional
funding would come from the federal
government so if you think about the
fact that the average cost overhead of a
lensey is about $150 it's probably gone
up since the last an time I analyzed
that in my in my opinion if you have
10,000 lnas they should be paying that
full cost um now I don't know how much
thhs is recovering from CMS but I
suspect that it's probably sufficient to
cover that um but I don't know what that
looks like okay thank you
okay representative Schmid thank you mam
chair uh is this question this is a
question of the chair is this an early
bill I knew somewhere but I don't have
it in my head I'll get back to you on it
okay is it going to a subcommittee it is
definitely going to subcommittee I I I
assume that but I never like to assume
things uh if I can ask so uh
um the the the subcommittee situation
because we're talking about a lot of
people and potentially a lot of money
here so uh I'm going to restrict some of
my questioning to the subcommittee but
um director Courtney uh roughly how many
people are be talking about here in New
Hampshire I think about 10,000 maintain
their LNA lure that
doesn't give us a good idea of who's
practicing um so a lot of people just
maintain their license without regard to
whether or not they're using
it and how many pink cards do we have
from we have a number of people here
interested in this bill how many pink
cards do we have from there are six
people
regarding Medical Imaging many of them
students one person that I believe is
concerned about the registry of medical
technicians and three people regarding
the Board of Nursing
thank
you
so all right we're good okay thank you
thank you for your time appreciate
it
um been Bradley with the hospital
Association since that's the employer of
most of these
folks looks like it must
be
it's
early good morning Madam chair I'm going
to pretend I made the morning testimony
follow my uh follow my written testimony
my name is Ben Bradley for the record
the vice president of state government
relations with the New Hampshire
Hospital Association representing all
our 26 Community Hospitals as well as
specialty hospitals throughout New
Hampshire uh as you may know last year's
budget negotiations contemplated several
Provisions to reform professional LIC
insure in the office of professional
liur and certification including the
consolidation or elimination of certain
professional boards as noted by the
sponsor hb1 1410 mirrors many of those
changes proposed last year in hb2 with
regard to changes proposed for licensed
nursing assistance it appears lnas will
be able to retain their title as
licensed nursing assistants but instead
of applying for lure through the Board
of Nursing and paying a licensing fee
the office of professional licensure and
certification and the Board of Nursing
will simply require their registration
which is in line with Federal
Regulations Additionally the Board of
Nursing would still retain oversight of
LNA education programs and ensure
integrity and
accountability We Believe licensed
nursing assistants should be given the
opportunity to weigh in on how these
changes excuse me Mr Bradley you don't
need to read this to us okay we we've
all it is a requirement for for
membership on this committee so I check
it what understood what's your your if
you just explain the highlights to us
it's much more effective sure so um we
believe the licensed nursing assistant
should be able to weigh in uh on how the
changes could be beneficial to their
profession
um when it comes to uh repealing the
medical Imaging and radiation therapy
board um we believe that a thorough
analysis should be uh done to continue
to continue to be done to determine
whether New Hampshire would be an
outlier uh among other states um and the
consequences of repealing the license
for these IND whether the consequences
would be in the best interest of the
professionals licensed um as it relates
to the board of registration for medical
technicians um at this point we're
neutral um our hospitals interact with
the board of medical with medical
technician registry
regularly
um
um however we're uncertain of the value
that the registry brings to their role
of ensuring Public Safety is
supported um we would encourage all
parties including individuals subject to
the registry uh to uh engage and fully
evaluate the scope and function of the
Medtech registry um
thanks for the opportunity to weigh in
are there
questions all right thank you very
much represent excuse me representative
gold do you have a question I do thank
you can you answer whether or not all
the hospitals in your Association
require background checks criminal
history background checks for lnas yes
my understanding is they do as part of
their accreditation requirements for
staff thank you working in their
hospitals
right Rebecca
shy hello my name is Rebecca Sky I'm the
execu I director of the state Commission
on Aging and sitting here with me is
Susan buckston I'm the state long-term
care utsman and also a member of the New
Hampshire State Commission on Aging the
New Hampshire State thank you for the
opportunity to speak with you here today
uh the state Commission on Aging was uh
created during the 2019 legislative
session its Chief charge is to gu is to
um guide the state the governor and the
state legislature on issues related to
aging and with that in mind we did want
to provide some input on the bill that
you're considering hb1 1410 I do have a
written testimony that I will share um
with you it it um compiles some points
raised by various commission members in
regarding this bill um as it is written
the state Commission on Aging and the
long-term care and budman's office um
oppose it um both the the portions
related to MedEx and the portions Rel
related to removing the lure of nursing
assistant um I'm just going to hit a
couple of the highlights from
uh let me see uh so among um use of a
registry does not enable a board to
determine the scope of practice of
nursing assistance or MedEx um that is
um to identify what they are permitted
to do or not do Healthcare is a dynamic
profession and those who practice
Healthcare must continuously adap their
knowledge and practice um by who without
these without the the um without the
these boards who will make the decision
about what the scope of practice is for
these
professions uh there is concern about
that uh that related to lnas that um
Federal Regulation requires nursing
assistance to receive um 12 hours of um
annual Continuing Education Without The
Lure um there's questions about how that
will um that whose burden will that fall
to to maintain that um that level of
continuing education and there's concern
that it will fall to
employers
um reading down uh
so licensed medical uh um so lnas are in
every sector of the healthcare industry
licing of nursing assistance creates a
higher standing standard of safety the
commission's understanding is that lnas
um do represent a disproportionate
number of of complaints that are made to
the uh Board of lure removing um
removing the
lur it just does not seem advisable in
this circumstance um less oversight
doesn't seem uh to ensure this uh safety
in every sector um that we need I am are
there I just want to make sure there's a
particular point that you wanted to
raise yeah I so I I think one of the
other points that should be considered
is that the license adds a certain
stature to for licensed nursing
assistance and at a time when we really
want to raise this profession up due to
the the critical Workforce shortage in
healthc care this could be perceived
negatively that they're losing lure and
and instead becoming a registry and I
would um suggest that it as director
Courtney alluded to looking to um
streamline the process of the registry
and the lure to make it a little less
cumbersome for those individuals so we
continue to have um a lure which begins
to set that career pathway for
individuals who become nursing
assistants to continue their career in
healthcare with additional lure can I
inter representative schmi thank you so
uh because I'm not sure how long your
testimony is going to take I'm wondering
whether you can just address what a
remark you just made so if if that
proposed or cons contemplated change
were to go through would that have an
impact on the cost to the to the lnas
themselves in terms of
registration there is no cost for the
registration there is a cost for the
lure which as director Courtney you know
addressed um does not cover the cost of
the lure and that would have to be I
believe would have to be studied how to
address that okay thank you thank
you there there's just one final point
that I would like to make from this
licensed nursing assistants are
individually accountable for the
Professional Standards under their
license how are however certified
nursing assistants work under the
guidance and direction of a licensed
nurse who is then accountable under his
own her own license for their
performances nurses have a voice that
they are uncomfort not comfortable
accepting this responsibility and this
raises concerns for the turn additional
turnover of licensed nursing nurses and
long-term care that was raised to us by
a a long-term care
provider thank you that's a very valid
point representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair so as was
indicated in earlier testimony there are
some
10,000 uh lnas in New Hampshire
currently my understanding is that we
have somewhat different structure in New
Hampshire than than virtually all the
other states to the degree that we would
uh entertain some kind of change how
much of a disruption would that make to
these 10,000 individuals in New
Hampshire it depends on the change I'm
sure I I think that would be my answer
it would depend on what the change is um
but as I said I I think we need to
consider that um
we're not devaluating de you know
devaluing these individuals that have
that are doing this
work representative G thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question I uh support 100% what you're
saying in terms of status for licensing
my question is I heard um director
Courtney say that that really the
registration is a license and would be
considered a license and that by
streamlining in and combining the two is
it really a change in status or is it
just that we've added this additional
burden that we can redefine what's
currently called registration on a list
to licensing would that satisfy it do
you
think in all honesty it it it wasn't
clear a registry is different than
licensing I would it's not
clear would some would an LNA be able to
to say that they're still an LNA that
they're a licensed nursing assistant
where they become a CNA then a a
certified nursing assistant and does
that still make them feel like they are
part of the um an equal member of the
healthcare team providing um vital care
these are people who are the most
intimate of of almost anyone in the
healthcare team with the people that
they're serving providing very personal
care thank you I was one and my daughter
is hasard Doctor as a nurse
practitioners so thank you very much
okay represent
mudy thank you madam chair a quick uh
question in terms of how many lnas how
many CNAs in the
state I believe the Board of Nursing
would be better able to answer that
question okay thank you
correct um so but the this um State
Commission on Aging has studied the
issue of what is the workforce that we
need in this state um there's a National
Organization Phi that studies the Direct
Care Workforce uh they feel um they have
made estimations that we will need a
significant number of more Nur um
certified licensed nursing assistance in
the
future thank you represent Brown uh
thank you madam chair and thanks for
taking my question going back to
something you said it might be outlined
in your written testimony a little bit
better um you said less oversight
doesn't ensure safety at least that's
what I wrote down you may not have said
those exact words but uh and and anyone
else who comes up to testify
subsequently it'd be interested to hear
their thoughts on that um so this
you you believe that this change in
process might result in less oversight
and less oversight could be a safety
concern is is am I translating what you
said I think I asked you four
questions so I think that um when we
talk about some of the the requirements
of the the licensing versus the registry
process we have a a Workforce that's
very Trent and I I think that the the
benefits of having um the responsibility
of lure which puts the responsibility on
the individual is probably going to um
be provide for better oversight if that
makes sense um an employer is not going
to have the average the average employer
is not going to have a long tenure with
that individual to be able to maintain
their oversight of their continuing
education for instance um okay thank you
and it's my understanding of the of the
process um that um that the and I do not
want to speak for director Courtney and
the
um um but it's my understanding that the
that there's that the office of of of
professional lur is is moving towards
conducting the investigations and that
the boards are moving towards the
adjudication process of of overseeing um
of of hearings related to complaints
and it's that type of process if you
lose one piece of that what happens to
the whole the process as a whole I think
that's where some of the concerns are
coming from thank you
okay representative Schmid brief one
thank you uh are you going to either or
both of you going to be available for
the
subcommittee absolutely thank
you
okay thank you very
much all
right
oops probably going to mangle this name
Danny ding
Dingle dimple for representing the
nursing
association my handwriting was really
bad on that one uh my name is Pam
denapoli I'm a registered nurse I live
in Manchester and I'm a member of the um
n New Hampshire Nurses Association
Commission on government Affairs um I'm
not going to take a lot of your time
because the previous testimony um
addressed a lot of the um issues that I
want so just to reiterate this was an
hb2 last year it was pulled out um at
that time New Hampshire Nurses
Association opposed those Provisions we
were happy when it got pulled out for a
further study um I think there are some
improvements made by this hb1 1410 but
there are still some concerns that we
have that need continued thorough study
um some of those are um the onus on the
employers so the previous discussion
about regulation and over site would
fall to the employers we do have a
document that shows that these
Registries there's a number of people
that are maintained on the registry
despite disciplinary action despite
having lost their um certification so to
speak so there are some concerns with
maintaining a registry um I think that
we're concerned um as also was
previously talked about the um impact on
the pipeline when we surveyed our um
licensed nursing assistants 70% of them
wanted to maintain the license because
they felt like the professional stature
was really important to them um we're
concerned that um the scope of practice
isn't well defined So currently there's
a different scope of practice for alenas
that work in a nursing home versus a
hospital and so those would have to be
um Justified there's concern about
delegation so if these um individuals
were no longer licensed would a licensed
registered nurse be able to Del at to an
unlicensed person and that's a concern
to us uh there's a concern about what we
call these people and it seems silly
because a nursing assistant is a nursing
assistant but uh are we calling a
licensed nursing assistant somebody when
they're not licensed um a certified
nursing assistant would be different but
have the same scope of practice are they
in the in the bill itself it was called
nurses aid nurses assistant licensed
nursing assistant so the the title needs
to be justified and then also shared
with those current lnas um and then
finally what's the Authority for the
Board of Nursing so will the authority
of the Board of Nursing for um
disciplinary action still be as rigorous
as it may be now because it was pointed
out that there are a number of elenes
who um are in the pipeline for
disciplinary
action thank you are there
representative
Schmidt thank you madam
chair so um
registered
nurses uh
RNs um are in point of fact licensed um
even though they're still called RNs
nobody says registered nurses
anymore uh but it's become uh the title
like CPAs are certified called certified
and your question please yes so how does
that aspect um you know touch on the
question you just raised that's a good
point um I think registered nurse is an
accepted title throughout the country
what we have the problem with the CNAs
so in some like Massachusetts they're
called certified nursing assistance in
New Hampshire they're licensed nursing
assistants so the name becomes I think
important because we want to talk Apples
to Apples and I think that was talked
about with the transitory nature of this
job you could be a CNA in Massachusetts
come to New Hampshire to be in LNA and
there's some confusion there so I I
think that that's really it's just for
purposes of
clarity thank you and and if I can just
make one last point on the composition
of the Board of Nursing um I think that
there was there was mentioned that um
that the board would be right sized if
they cut it down from 13 to 7 and I
think
um we we need to hear from the Board of
Nursing whether or not that that's going
to meet their eff efficienc needs
because if the purpose of all of this is
efficiency then we have to have a
right-sized board as
well thank
you thank you Mani thank you um I just
have a question for you um I can ask
this is the right person to ask my
previous question correct Madam Cher no
no okay I'll defer she's she's a member
of the nurses Professional Association
right um Samantha O'Neal is here for
this board of
nursing
um I really hope you won't need 10
minutes good morning and thank you um my
name is Samantha O'Neal and I'm the
public member and chair of the Board of
Nursing I've been on the board of
nursing since September
2017 um I do have a four-page um
testimony that has been given out I
don't plan to read it um I think the
best use of the time would be uh for me
to highlight some specifics and then
answer uh some of the questions that
have come up that I think were posed to
other people but were meant uh for
me so um the board oversees um advanced
practice nurses registered nurses
nursing instructors licensed practical
nurses licensed nursing assistant and
medical nursing assistant we have just
shy of 50,000 lenes the number of lnas
in the state currently are
12,000 um and approximately 1,000 of
them are medical nursing assistants you
need um an LNA to be an m&a so you need
to have that license prior to being a a
medical nurse assistant which allows you
to dispense medications which is a huge
component in our long-term care and uh
facilities and our nursing homes um we
currently do not have certified nursing
assistants which was a your question was
um we do have a lot of the um a lot of
my testimony on behalf of the board um
has been stated previously by um uh
speakers that came before me um we do we
do have concerns um representative Gould
uh we have concerns about the background
checks as well um as a note
81% of all LNA applications come before
the board due to background check
um there are many that do get their
license but many of them have to come
before the board um to speak about their
background so we can have an
understanding of what happened and what
they have in place uh for them to be uh
act practicing uh actively within the
community because lnas they're in the
hospitals but they're also home care
home uh and also long-term care and
that's where our most vulnerable
patients are and we want to make sure
and we have had people people before us
for the board for theft um and taking
advantage of um people in in home care
and also long-term care facilities so we
want to make sure that they have clean
background checks to make sure that they
um are safe for our
citizens um excuse me you said that 81%
of the applicants have something on
their background check that has to go to
the board
correct thank you for that information
you're welcome and also 39%
of the complaints that come before the
board are for
lnas
39% um there was someone who asked I
believe it was representative Schmidt um
regarding how would the change impact
the lnas it would depend on what the
change is um I think you know from a
board perspective we understand that
there's challenges with the workforce we
face it every day um I am a human
resource professional I worked eight
years in healthcare I currently don't
work in healthcare right now um so I
understand firsthand the challenges with
Workforce and we we obviously have made
changes on streamlining the process for
lenses making it easier um and but also
making sure there's a balance between
streamlining the process and also making
sure that the people are safe to
practice and they have the skills needed
to practice to take care of patients and
there's a balance there and I think you
know the board feels very strongly that
we would be willing to have
conversations with any of of this
committee also the New Hampshire Nurses
Association and any other um individual
from the constituents that would be able
to work collaboratively to come up with
um a solution to this to be able to make
sure that we're meeting the needs of the
workforce while also making sure that
those in the workforce are practicing
safely and not cutting Corners to make
sure that we have people to do that we
want to make sure that we're having the
right people do that and I think you
know one of the missions of the Board of
Nursing is making sure that people are
safe to practice and make sure the
members of our community are safe and
that is the most important for us as I'm
sure it is for all of
you thank you representative man py
thank you madam chair thank you for that
clarification so now my qu you know
having done a non-medical inhome care
coordination and starting something in
New Hampshire uh in my previous life but
um with that where does the home health
aid fit in with the LNA CNA if we don't
have CNA so are they taking the place
especially for in home care so there's
different positions for Home Care the
those that are not licensed do not fall
under the preview of The Board of
Nursing so I honestly don't know how
many are providing home care but they
they can't work they cannot do the work
of a licens nursing assistant so people
can't practice outside of their specific
scope that's relevant to their license
and if somebody is not licensed they
should not be doing things that are
responsibilities of those that are
licensed thank
you yes um I'd also like to speak about
the composition of the board thank you
that's that's a big piece for us um so
the board is made up of a cross
functional group of people um and in TW
we currently have we were just approved
in 2023 to increase our number from 11
to 13 um which was just done not even a
year ago um we have a cross
representation of
aprns um we have two public members we
have lnas RN's and lpn's all of which
have different experience so we have
people that have home care experience
long-term care experience ambulatory
hospital and we have all of those
different lenses of which again are
close to 50,000 come before the board
for a variety of reasons and tapping
into that expertise and knowledge of
that cross functional group of people is
really Paramount to making sure that we
are one understanding best practices
understanding the situation of whatever
is coming before us and we tap into that
level of expertise every single board
meeting uh to make sure that we are
making sound decisions because the
decisions we're making are not just
impacting somebody's position their
their livelihood their license can
depend on what they've done versus our
decision on what to do for them moving
forward so having that level of
expertise is Paramount and decreasing
that number is is we we honestly don't
support that and feel that it's going
going to have a negative impact on um on
our decision making thank you does the
Board of Nursing have any trouble
getting a quorum we do not not at all
even in our emergency situations we do
not have a problem uh coming up with the
Quorum at all thank
you thank you represent
BR I wanted to
um ask you to share with the board
what an m& does because it's very
important what their responsibilities
are as far as
medication and the kind of training that
they get and that this these this is the
kind of work that's available for an LNA
if they wish to um excuse me
representative gr I it's fascinating but
I kind of think that belongs in the
subcommittee would you agree oh okay
thanks could I just comment I won't
answer specifically but you brought
something up that I think is important
is is a lot of the the LNA the m& the RN
the LPN those are all career advancement
opportunities for people in the in the
nursing practice so you know when you
look at the the scope it would be LNA m&
LPN RN APRN so th there is a direct
career opportunity and growth path for
people that do need various levels of
experience to help them in their
advancement of of care um and Licensing
within the the workforce and the the
hospital
Association thank you very much thank
you I I hope that we we can get some
help from the board and our subcommittee
we would be honored to participate thank
you thank you so much that will
help uh Brandy
kusan
to please turn your microphone
on thank you uh good morning thank you
for this opportunity to be here today um
you guys have my written testimony so in
the in the uh timely constraints we have
I'll kind of
paraphrase
um Madam chairperson all the members of
the House executive departments and
administration committee
my name is Brandy cussen I am the
President of the New Hampshire Society
of radiologic technologist as well as
the board chair for the state of New
Hampshire's Medical Imaging and
radiation therapist
board I am here before you today as the
main voice of the medical imaging
professions in the state of New
Hampshire we are committed to the
advancement of education and
professional status of credential
technologist I'm here today asking on
their behalf as well as mine that this
committee vote HB be 1410 in expedient
to
legislate the biggest issue that Medical
Imaging faces is this going away which
will increase unsafe practice for the
patient and not only for the patient but
for the practitioner as
well the patient rarely is in a position
to judge the qualifications of the
operator or the quality of the
examination let alone their radiation
dosage the chest x-ray when performed by
an uneducated untrained operator has the
potential to deliver 100 times the
radiation dose to the patient as the
same procedure performed by a properly
educated radiologic
technologist education knowledge is the
Paramount for safety for our patients
and that's really what we need if we
take away lure then we're taking away
that level of over oversight and safety
for our patients and for the people that
are working in the
industry if you don't know how to
operate the equipment or to expose it
properly then you're going to expose
yourself to unsafe radiation levels just
as you would to the
patient the New Hampshire Hospital
Association um was asked a question
about what the majority of the United
States are in regards to lure and over
45 states have some form of lure in
their
state um happy to answer any questions
that anybody
has representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair so you
understand that this uh this bill
involves a lot more than your profession
so the idea of of itl doesn't really
resolve the issues that this bill you
know tries to deal with so um would you
be a you know open to alternatives to an
itl motion sure I would love if you
would strike us from the bill that would
be great thank you that's nice and
simple we will consider it I I I was not
asked to ask that question but it's an
obvious one all right thank
you thank you for your
testimony all right and I have four
students I hope that you will be brief
and not and not repeat what's been said
already Ronda
white good morning uh Madam chair and
committee I have a written testimony
from Dr sprag the chief radiologist at
CMC uh may I read it for the
record you can put it into the record we
do you have copies for us or just one it
is in bry's packet the packet that was
up prior we will be reading reading this
if you could give us the highlights we
would appreciate absolutely uh Dr sprag
agrees with the New Hampshire Society of
radiologic technologists the American
registry of radiologic technologists and
the American Society of radiologic
technologists that removing lens here in
New Hampshire does create a safety
hazard for both uh patients and uh
employees operating the medical imaging
equipment
um as a radiologic technologist we spend
at least two years in school most of us
it ends up being about four by the time
we're done learning uh Anatomy
physiology radio radiation physics uh
patient and Personnel safety and without
that you could really be putting a lot
of people at risk of overdosing
radiation and
uh for instance injecting an air bow
list through uh CT injector or
aspirating barium if Pro improperly
given to a
patient thank you that's very clear
question all right thank you very much
yes representative Brown uh thank you
madam chair so following up what I asked
before you see that if this passes it
will change the amount of education
required and therefore that's a safety
issue yeah actually Dr sprag did mention
that yeah I'm trying to read this I'm
sorry I apologize continue okay uh he
did mention that hospitals would no
longer be required to hire license
technologist which could leave a lot of
gray area and what kind of education is
required for the job okay okay fair
enough thank you very much thank
you all right Jessica
Horton
good morning my name is Jessica Horton
and I am a registered radiologic
technologist for the State of New
Hampshire and um I am also one of the
two program directors for uh two of the
accredited radiologic technology
programs in the state of New Hampshire
so just to summarize um I also I'm on
the state the New Hampshire Society of
radiologic technologist board so I am an
advocate and an educator and a
practicing radiologic technologist on a
perdm basis primarily my role is to
educate students in the state of New
Hampshire um to go out and serve our
communities and in that role one of the
most important aspects of their
education is learning human anatomy and
physiology proper radiographic
positioning and radiation protection so
Brandy custen came up here earlier and
mentioned um the importance of proper
positioning regarding any sort of
Imaging modality that is performed and
without proper positioning and radiation
protection uh basically an individual
that would be performing any sort of
Medical Imaging study would be guessing
how to perform that study so I'm asking
you to please consider uh my strong
opposition to this bill because the fact
that our patients would not be receiving
Safe Care in any of their medical
imaging
studies thank you
representative gold thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question will you be available for the
subcommittee on this bill
sure excellent
okay thank you for your testimony thank
you Connor
fuger
tonium thank you for allowing me to
speak today um I just wanted to voice my
concerns to this bill due to patient
safety um whenever you're a patient in a
hospital you expect that you were going
to receive Quality Care by
individuals that are well capable of
doing their job and especially with um
radiation safety I'm currently a senior
student and there's been a lot of
learning curves and different aspects
that go into this and whenever you go in
if we didn't have properly trained staff
members that are capable of knowing what
what they are uh doing this could cause
many safety concerns It Could lack the
quality of care it could endanger the
patient along with yourself
um and with that being said it is is
rather dangerous to have people that
could slip through the cracks without
this lure in place and cause uh harm to
our community as a whole when Medical
Imaging is necessary in a hospital or
Orthopedic
setting thank you for your testimony
thank you for allowing me to speak
oh Brett
cra
good morning um I'm bre RN and I'm here
to speak on the behalf of the Imaging
programs um I just want to bring up the
fact that um getting an x-ray is a
prescription um you're prescribed an
x-ray you're press red the dosage of
what it takes to get the proper image um
without a properly training in person
how do they know what dosage um each
machine you kind of learn so each
machine at every facility you got to
learn a little bit to tweak it so you're
given a proper
dosage that's all I really have to say
okay thank you for coming to talk to us
today questions okay thank you very
much Dr
Sherman
thank you madam chair um and thank you
for the opportunity to speak on this
bill uh for the record my name is Tom
Sherman former State Rep state senator
and retired
gastroenterologist um from Ry um I'd
like to speak to two parts of the bill
um I think the nursing uh rules have
been covered by people much more expert
than I um but on page six lines 22
through 26 I would ask that you strike
this
repeal um last year I believe we had a a
repeal of the Medtech board before you
and I spoke at length about the history
of the Medtech board a be a brief
reminder years in 2011 my work partner
and I discovered a hepatitis C outbreak
at exitor hospital 32 patients were
involved Senator Cataldo's mother was
one of the victims that died of that the
bills that came out of that at least
four made New Hampshire one of the
safest states in the country against
drug diversion and the um criminal who
actually did that was a radiology tech
in in um and there was no
mechanism to actually track him so U
representative Copeland and I came
together representative Copeland is a
republican we came together and we took
a bill that already existed which was
the bill to create the board of medical
technicians the board of registry and
worked on it in a bipartisan fashion for
over a year to come up with the Medtech
board the goal of the board and this is
what's critically important the goal of
the B board was to close a gap in state
monitoring of people who have access to
patients and dangerous drugs like
opioids that was the goal of the board
so if you are a medical assistant you're
not licensed or registered or otherwise
classified anywhere in New Hampshire and
that's still true unless you have access
to patients and controlled sub
substances then you have to register
with the board of medical
technicians is this a decade later the
best way to handle this to close that
Gap I'm not sure but I think the fact
that we have not had any further
outbreaks in the state of New Hampshire
may be a testimony to this is at least a
smart way to do it but as director
Courtney has said they have trouble
Staffing the board and may be another
alternative to it but repealing it all
together reopens that
Gap according to the federal attorney
who prosecuted katowski in that case
8,500 people were put at risk nationally
by one person and his final stop was at
exor in exor New Hampshire and we
stopped him in New
Hampshire it was the third largest
hepatitis C outbreak due to drug
diversion in the country and many people
got sick many people died and most of
them were elderly because it happened in
the cath
lab so I would ask that you not repeal I
would commit to working with director
Courtney to some other less cumbersome
more efficient way of monitoring people
this is not a clinical evaluation of
people's performance it's simply a way
to make sure that if there is somebody
in the state of New Hampshire in this
position which I've already defined that
we know about them and we also know if
there's a disciplinary action or even a
criminal criminal uh prosecution of
them uh I that would keep the Gap closed
the
second part that I want to speak on is
the repeal of the board of radiology
technicians this bill this board was
created by Senator Carson who is chair
of Edna on the Senate side not anymore
not anymore but I I'm old I've been she
was when I was here lots of expertise on
the boards coming from Senator Carson
but the most important part was one of
the pieces of testimony that happened
during the formation of this board which
wowed the committee at the time
and that was when somebody said that in
a dental office the receptionist did the
uh actual
X-rays and when and it was somebody who
was on the committee in the
house and the radiology tech who was
actually testifying at the time said did
they Shield
you and they said
no the gentleman's face went
white that's what we're going back to
we're going back to receptionists being
able to perform potentially dangerous
procedures because they don't know they
don't have the education they don't have
the
certification that this board provides
in how they actually dose the radiation
how they protect the patient and
themselves from the
radiation um so I would ask you to give
us a chance to close that Gap in another
way if there are problems with the board
of medical technicians rather than a
repeal and uh the second one is please
leave the radiology tech board intact
it's critical and it will be life saving
thank you I'm happy to take any
questions thank
you just a brief one representative
manuti thank you I haven't even turned
my
microphone off sorry so how will this
rule change affect the larger sector
where Home Care Aging in place outside
the hospital kind of thing so the
oversight on that critical function that
LNA the technicians all provide will
this Reduce by repealing this will that
reduce the oversight you know honestly I
think you've had people who are much
more expert already speak to that and
and I'm just a simple Country Doctor I'm
not a nurse so um I wouldn't I think
you've had the experts already talk
about that if that's okay no that's we'd
rather you didn't uh waffle for a bit
we're all right oh I'm not waffling
Madam chair thank thank you very much I
appreciate that all right we have
another hearing at
115 uh unless there is someone who needs
to speak on this bill now is there okay
thank you very much for being here we
will take that information to the
subcommittee and I'm going to close the
hearing for the purposes of the
committee we will not have a session
next Thursday we will have u a full day
of hearing
ings THS next Thursday the
25th
a regulation and lure of Deputy
Physicians and um representative Brian
Cole are you presenting the bill
okay
thank you Mr chair
members uh 1427 is establishing the
regulation and licensure of Deputy
Physicians so this is a bill that has
come up in the past but there was always
a
problem with the the verbage of the
title they wanted to call it assistant
position or phys assistant so you can
see where that's very confusing between
the two so it changed the language to
Deputy physician to make the distinction
so that's one of the first major
distinctions that's in this
bill now why are we asking you know why
are we bringing this bill to the
committee in for New Hampshire currently
there's about 5,000 people in the United
States that have all the qualifications
to become a doctor but they can't find
the residency to do
so so they passed all their tests they
pass all them exams the last thing they
need to do is to follow or Shadow
somebody in the medical community key to
get that
residency what this bill does is allow
that door to open up for New Hampshire
now there's already nine states in the
state in the country that are enacted
this and they're taking all that medical
talent and bringing it to their states I
think that's something that we can do
here for New
Hampshire so that's a very brief
overview of the bill all the technical
stuff in all the rsas I'm sure you can
look that up on your own and go through
that technical data but that's the Crux
of the
bill so I'll inate any questions I know
it sounds kind of simple it's a
complicated bill but I mean that's
really what it's about great thank you
for your testimony uh are there any
questions sure okay representative G
thank you what do you mean they don't
have availability of residency I don't
understand residency I passed out I put
a a thing on everybody's desk so there's
an article related to this and then this
testimony from Ross Terry who was a
former rep he's also a um a
pharmacist so residency you need to be
matched up with a doctor and you Shadow
this person for x amount of time and you
learn how to you know become a doctor
that's how you learn how to get your
license to to practice medicine but
there's only so much of that pairing in
the United
States in 2021 there was 4,000 people
looking for residency this year it's
5,000 people looking for residency so
it's becoming more and more of a problem
so it has to do more with
pairing and opening up that Avenue
there's only so much
residency so these people can't find the
residency to become a doctor follow
up so residency is usually specific to a
c
certain to a certain segment of the
medical field for example you have
anesthesiologists you have thorasic
surgeons you have orthopedists so is
there a specific residency that's not
available to these individuals it's the
fact that there's only so much
residency there's only so much residency
available so if you make this residency
available to somebody that is a
specialist like that and they can Shadow
two or three people they can open their
residency that way they can ear The
Residency that
way thank
you representative Schmidt you do you
have a
question well uh I know that residency
to my knowledg is usually in involves a
an affiliation with a with a teaching
medical school so Dartmouth has Med
medical school right but UNH does not
have a medic medical school I believe I
do not know I believe
so
um do we have anybody from Dartmouth
here that you know can talk to us about
this situation representative Cole you
said there's only so many residents how
many do you have the number for
for medical school graduates versus
residencies the number that I have are
people that have passed all the
qualifications federally to become a
doctor they just need to earn they need
to find a place to Res find that
residency and right now there's
currently about 5,000 people in the
United States that can't find residency
ah thank you that's a is that 5,000 per
year or 5,000 accumulative in 2021 it
was 4,000 for the entire United States
this year or 2023 it was 5,000 so the
it's be it's a growing problem thank you
yep okay thank you for your testimony
thank
you
okay avah
Hawks good afternoon Madame chair
members of the committee I just passed
out a stack of my testimony so I'll
introduce myself a little bit slowly uh
for the record my name is Ava Hawks and
I am the director of advocacy for the
New Hampshire Medical Society um the
medical society strongly opposes House
Bill
1427 um House Bill 1427 seeks to allow
medical school graduates who do not have
who have not completed graduate medic
medical education or residency or
completed the medical licensing
examination series a series that tests
if future Doctors Medical knowledge and
preparedness for independent practice to
become licensed Healthcare Providers
called Deputy Physicians as this bill
sets forth the provisions set forth in
this bill would dramatically lower the
standard of training and competency
demonstration that our providers across
Specialties and the state work so hard
to implement and frankly the bill would
unjustly risk patient safety in New
Hampshire uh the American Medical
Association or the AMA the largest and
only National Association that conven
190 States and other special uh
specialty medical societies has also
gone on the record opposing any efforts
in states that create pathways for
Deputy Physicians or previously coined
as assistant physicians in proposed
legislation in 2019 that was defeated as
well um and these efforts to circumvent
the traditional residency training and
standards put forth by the accreditation
Council for graduate medical education
program or acgme which you'll hear folks
experts behind me speak to more uh
eloquently today while the society's
membership is acutely aware of the
impact the current Healthcare Workforce
shortage has on access to care in New
Hampshire our state's Physicians and the
medical profession as a whole are not
willing to risk patient safety and
health outcomes by licensing medical
school graduates who lack the imperative
and life-saving Skillets acquired during
residency training all in the name of
increased access to care um for these
reasons the medical society joins
countless other others including the New
Hampshire Board of Medicine and strongly
opposing House Bill 1427 and encourages
the house Ena committee to recommend an
expedient to legislate on this bill to
ensure that we continue to prioritize
not undervalue the medical education
clinical training and high standards of
our states pH positions that have led to
our highquality healthare system I am
happy to attempt to take questions but I
know that there are a number of
Physicians and experts behind me that
will speak more eloquently to the
intricacies that go into the residency
programs in our state and what those
those those programs look
like okay Are there specific questions
repes it's not required representative
but go ahead and ask thank you madam
chair um
as you read this would a deputy
physician working under a physician
would that be similar to a
residency and anyone following you can
answer that question so I don't want to
football but I think the providers and
physicians in the room could really
eloquently speak to the differences
between the process that's outlined in
this bill in comparison to how these
residency programs work in our state
thank
you all right representative Smith
excuse me but how long are residency
usually is it a year two years so it
varies depending on the specialty on
average it's anywhere from 3 to five as
I understand it and there are some um
surgical residencies that last longer
than that and I I'm confident folks
directly behind me who plan to testify
can speak to their experiences they um
have has have a a facilitated reset
residency programs in our
state okay let me think about that
okay thank you thank you Christine
Stoddard um good afternoon my name is
Christine Stoddard and I'm the director
of uh public policy at by state Primary
Care Association we are also opposed by
state Primary Care Association is a
nonprofit that works to expand access to
health care services in especially in
medically underserved areas which is the
areas of the state that this bill is
targeting we also represent New
Hampshire's community health centers
which are regulated by the federal
government and they operate in medically
underserved areas our community health
centers cannot employ the clinicians
that this bill is proposing to create we
rely on Federal malpractices Insurance
to ensure our doctors and the safety of
um patients in New Hampshire they would
not cover um the clinicians that this
bill is proposing to create we are also
not able to get reimbursed for the care
that would be provided under this bill
um by any carrier especially CMS the
centers for Medicaid and Medicare
Services we do not have the ability to
float Health Care Services provided by
clinicians that we cannot get reimbursed
for um so in summary we can't afford to
employ this type of um clinician that
this bill is proposing to create so we
would ask that you recommend the bill be
inexpedient to legislate because we
can't employ them we would rather create
additional residency programs and more
training opportunities for clinicians
than reduce the requirements to practice
medicine in the state of New Hampshire
I'd be happy to answer any questions if
you have them okay thank you
representative Mani thank you madam
chair thank you for your testimony and
thank you for taking my question is it
true that currently
existing um residency
programs uh for doctors you know who
have they are not completely filled in
some places because people are burnt out
and don't want to get into medical field
as a
practicing um doctors is that have you
heard that thank you representative for
the question I think that the workforce
shortages that we are experienc are very
complicated there's not just one reason
why PE why we are experiencing shortages
but yes there is definitely burnout
amongst medical professionals across the
country and the state of New Hampshire
yes representative gold hi thank you uh
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question my question has to is
a follow-up and it has to do with
residencies and everything I've heard
I've never experienced one but
everything I've heard and read from
doctors about residencies is that the
way they're set up they are very
unhealthy for the people enduring them
do you have anything to do with how
residencies are set up and as an
alternative to this if we're going to um
expand residencies can they be made more
healthy for the people trying to do them
I think that's beyond the scope of this
bill to be honest with you
representative go thank you I'll accept
that there thank you you're you're not
responsible for residency you just take
the doctor we are not representative
Maguire thank you
I'm all right any other
questions
thank you
okay pamy
[Music]
napole thank you um Pam Denley New
Hampshire Nurses Association I'm a nurse
and uh recently retired from the
University of New Hampshire um the New
Hampshire Nurses Association um like we
did in 2019 opposes this bill
um we recognize there's a need for
Primary Care Pro providers in
underserved areas but the solution as
proposed is not uh hb1
1427 currently the state licensed
independent practitioners such as
Physicians assistants and advanc
registered nurse practitioners hb1 1427
would offer medical school graduates a
pathway to MD by practicing in this same
independent practitioner role in New
Hampshire arnps Nur n practitioners um
like those in 25 other states enjoy full
practice Authority allowing them to
practice free of MD supervision and with
similar skills and competencies the
American Medical Association has long
advocated that the Education and
Training to be a medical doctor must be
comprehensive including classroom
laboratory or Direct Care experiences
since the NP role was established in
1965 research has consistently
demonstrated the excellent outcomes and
highquality care provided by nurse
practitioners the body of literature
supports the position that NPS provide
care that is safe effective patient
centered efficient Equitable and
evidence-based there is no such clear
evidence that medical student graduates
who have not matched with an accredited
residency training program can guarantee
the same
outcomes currently there are 2600 nurse
practitioners licensed in the state with
a pathway to train more
for example UNH has the advanced nursing
education Workforce Grant which is
funding to prepare Primary Care family
nurse practitioners and psych mental
health nurse practitioners to uh provide
care in Rural and underserved settings
uh currently medical school graduates do
not have to complete a Residency program
however they would need to complete a
Residency program to be licensed as an
independent practitioner residency
training means participating in gradu
medical education once a doctor in
training has completed their gme and has
passed two all three steps of the
training they can become practicing
Physicians Medical residencies last
anywhere between three and or more years
to substitute this highly structured
regulated medical Residency program with
a practice program with a single
practitioner has the potential to impact
the safety of many of the most
vulnerable patients in Rural and
underserved areas this is a d dangerous
substitution New Hampshire Nurses
Association strongly opposes this
legislation together with uh our
practice
Partners thank you
questions bany thank you thank you I
just have a question over there in the
corner um quick question in terms of the
workforce shortage for Physicians isn't
that true that since New Hampshire does
not have a medical school State Medical
scho school the only medical school we
have is Dartmouth that is creating a
acute shortage to have Physicians um I
think like what was said before that
there's a lot of reasons for shortage um
one of the things one of the reasons I
was pointing out the nurse practitioners
as independent providers is those
graduates often stay in New Hampshire
and a lot of the evidence is that while
Dartmouth is our medical school not many
of those continue to practice in New
Hampshire and representative maputi it's
not a local short shortage there's a
nationwide shortage of medical
professionals
corre representative Brown thank you
madam chair this will probably come up
in subcommittee more but
uh NPS as independent practitioners do
they require some kind of a residency or
something of that nature before they get
that far they have practicum hours that
they have to complete as part of their
program
yeah thank you very
much hly
Campion good afternoon Madam chair and
members of Edna uh my name is pully
Campion I am a former representative I
spent a year on this committee um and I
recognize some of my uh former uh
committee mates many of you are new
since that time but um it was was a
fascinating process for me I am a
registered nurse and I'm here today as a
member of the state Commission on Aging
um I also had the opportunity of uh
testifying on the floor actually um
against the floor of the house against
this bill the last time it came up 2018
and
2019 um and except for the title nothing
in the text has
changed um what I'd like to just
reinforce I have um testimony that I
emailed to each of you and I have copies
if you'd like um let me just pass that
around I'm not going to read it all you
had it in email you have it in hard copy
I've spoken with some of you um but I'd
like to make a couple of points um to
reinforce what has been said um but also
to speak specifically about the effect
on older adults of uh licensing um this
new form of providing
care we all recognize that there is a
shortage of primary care providers but
this is a very flawed solution to that
um and just to jump to the fact that we
don't have enough residency slots in the
country or in the state um uh Senate
Bill 403 actually proposes providing
funding to support a Family Practice
Residency program in Coos County um so
that's a potentially better way of
addressing the shortage of Physicians um
it's already been stated but I'll re um
emphasize the fact that um the deputy
physician the way this bill is written
would need to find a essentially a
mentor a collaborating physician who
would then be responsible for Designing
the equivalent of a Residency program
the language says with da HHS and with
medical schools um to be named and I
don't think that medical schools um have
volunteered to help um put their
energies into um designing this training
program versus those that have been
approved um by the accrediting
boards the deputy physician as outlined
in the um text would effectively
practice an equivalent way as a
physician
assistant um without the benefit of
being able to bill for services um as we
have
heard the proposed grant program um
would further promote a second level of
care to those already in greatest needs
and at greatest effect of the fact that
we don't we have inadequate Services
particularly in rural areas the effect
on older adults um would be such that
older adults those of us as we age and
we all are aging tend to to carry with
us our life experience that include
chronic
illnesses the care that I need is much
more sophisticated than the care that I
needed when I was younger um we need
care providers who are experienced and
knowledgeable in diagnosis and
recognition of um the difference between
an exacerbation of a chronic illness and
a new onset acute illness and this
particularly may show up in cases in
which m memory starts to fade it is not
true that we all lose our memories as we
age and we all develop dementia as we
age um and often there may be a
metabolic condition that causes changes
is changes in cognition or
mentation and if we have providers who
have no experience or limited experience
in patient care and don't have the
support they need to gain that
experience and that knowledge um we are
much more likely to see mistreatment and
diagnosis of acute
exacerbations um and of chronic
illnesses as well as new onset um in
addition I think the work the rules uh
and the effort and expense required to
to set up this program would distract
from all of those resources and the
effort that actually could go toward a
more um significant solution and with
that I ask that you vote itl um on this
um bad bill um I will also say the
sponsor um who introduced the bill
mentioned that there were a number of
states that have implemented this I
believe that that may not be the case um
Missouri uh to my knowledge is the only
state that has actually implemented this
role and hired individuals into it um a
number of other states in the 2017 2018
time period proposed legislation um but
to the extent I was able to um follow up
up on that it appears that they have not
been successful and I know that there
are experts behind me who will be able
to speak to that to a greater extent and
with that I'd accept any questions but
we have
experts all right thank you very much
thank
you okay Ben
Bradley
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record Ben Bradley
vice president state government
relations for the New Hampshire Hospital
Association I'm not going to read my
testimony that went around to the
committee uh as many of the points uh we
rais have been raised by others um I
list in bullet form on my testimony each
of those
concerns um want to reiterate our
opposition to
1427 uh with sever several concerns um
we have heard from colleagues in
Missouri that implemented this uh and
they've shared their experience um
challenges with securing malpractice
insurance challenges with securing
reimbursement uh from carriers and uh
Contracting with insurance I'm happy to
take your questions okay are
questions all right thank you for your
testimony Nick
penovich
turn your microphone on
please there you go there we go thank
you let me see what I look like um my
name is Nick penovich I've um lived in
the conquered area for 36 years I'm a
semi-retired uh General and vascular
surgeon um I don't operate anymore the
last 10 years but I've continued to
teach and literally this morning with
two Dartmouth medical students and two
residents from Dartmouth and I've done
that uh pretty much my whole career in
conquered and uh prior to that for about
eight years in Boston when I lived in
Massachusetts with medical students so I
have a fairly strong relationship with
teaching and it's been mostly uh in New
Hampshire entirely through Dartmouth one
of the questions yes there's only one
med school at Dartmouth um there are
other Med schools nearby and that's kind
of critical in this bill um because
there's some discussion of it on page
seven of adjacent met schools and
residency training programs um I'm not
representing anybody um other than uh
myself at this point um The Residency is
something that I went through many years
ago but I also was the director of the
surgical residency in Dartmouth we've
had a saddle and conquered for 35 years
were surgical residents in their second
and third year spend time and I was
director of that for about 15 years um
it's really different than the exposure
one gets to patients in med school um
and my did some calculation the typical
medical student spends their last two
years in hospital seeing patients that's
important because if you're going to
take care of patients you have to see
patients before you get the green light
to do that and typically that's about
4,000 hours those last two years if you
if you take two years of
residency uh which no residency in the
United States is two years they're three
years and more uh there was a time it
was one year that was called GP and you
you rotated through and so forth but if
you do two years of a typical residency
with the time constraints trying to be
respectful of their illness you know
time and so forth It's about 9,000 hours
in those two years so the typical
residency is a little under 15,000 hours
and and the difference is when you're a
medical student you're writing orders
you're observing you're studying you're
learning you're getting tested but you
don't really have responsibility for the
patient you can't write an order the
residency all of a sudden it flips
you're writing orders you're responsible
you're on night call you're making first
decisions and after about a year of that
you're supposed to get tested and that's
called level three so there's a dramatic
difference there's a lot of
responsibility that goes into the
typical residency no matter what field
it is Primary Care Surgery whatsoever
first year residency in most places is
very similar because it's being used to
seeing
patients um getting to this exam
part uh well I'll talk about step three
they didn't talk about step one or two
but one is after two years of med school
and what you're looking at is basic
science do you know Anatomy do you know
physiology do you know the structure of
the body do you know how to look under
the microscope and look at slides and
stuff like
that and once you start seeing patients
after those first two years in your
third and fourth year that second part
of the exam has to do a bit with
patients but has most mostly to do with
recognizing diseases and understanding
it book knowledge of diseases basically
pathology both clinical anatomical and
radiology and so forth so I typ I spend
time with 30-year medical students and
they're nowhere near uh being able to
take care of patients even at the end of
their fourth year the third test if you
look up or Google what the third test is
about is to whether they have clinical
judgment you don't get judgment until
you're actually respond responsible for
taking care of the patient you need to
have a year of that under your belt and
whether you're safe
unsupervised so residents take this test
while they residents after one year
somewhere usually between the first and
second year sometimes the third but the
goal is to have you to be safe
unsupervised and yet then more people
than not end up having one more year of
residency so there's a lot involved and
with this Deputy um you know we called
it Deputy physician now the last bill it
was a graduate um
physici there isn't this testing of
being able to make
judgment
um there was a time that states created
their own level three tests actually
load and two uh I'm old I'm 76 years old
and when I finished residency if I
wanted to practice in Florida finish my
residency in Boston go to Florida I'd
have to take a separate test in Florida
that doesn't exist anymore it's been 45
years I think since Florida has had its
own test that's relevant also I'm going
to get on to almost done with my
comments but um the thing that Disturbed
me most about this bill was I mean we
saw this stuff a couple years ago it
wasn't any different what I've talked
about now but this test this previous
bill was sort of a pilot thing does this
make sense can we do it and trying to
get support it didn't happen this one
isn't listed as a pilot bill it
basically is more detailed it's a lot
longer uh but if you go to page seven
line 17 I'm going to quote what it said
there basically it has a pathway for
Deputy Physicians to become fully
licensed uh in residency training if you
look at line 17 Page 7 the New Hampshire
ddhs commissioner as well as the Deans
of medical schools it's plural so it's
not just asking Dartmouth to get
involved it could be univers of Vermont
it could be U the main do school School
in bitterford it could be the four
Boston Medical Schools um so it
basically says the Deans of medical
schools and Primary Care directors to
develop and Implement educational
methods with collaborative practice to
facilitate the deputy Physician Medical
knowledge and capabilities which may
lead to credit towards a future
Residency program it's a little vague to
me um so I I feel it boy this I'm going
to contact people I know I know the dean
of the med school who I spoke to this
morning and I contacted the head of the
residency program in family practice and
Conquer The Family Practice program
conquer has been around 25 years um the
one in new one in Portsmouth I think is
three or four years old and we heard a
little bit about potentially one in that
is a solution creating more primary
family practice doctors within the state
that sended into the state so I just
assume the residency director uh at
conquered who I know very well so I
contact him two days ago neither of them
knew about this bill at all they knew
about the old one and one of them had
testified against it but it surprised me
a lot that the people who wrote up this
bill didn't communicate with residency
director in the state or the medical
school or the
dean um
so I don't think the homework was done
and and the homework may be where the
solution is the dean's comment to me
this morning was I would really like to
work with the state he actually spoke to
the governor he talked to me about
speaking to the governor ly in the last
few months about trying to work on this
problem because it's really a problem
and uh I think that's the way to go I
think is to engage the medical school uh
maybe with this new program up in cous
County so that do we have people who can
finish a Residency program and complete
the level three and the other part of
this bill in addition to creating a
method of residency talked about an
alternative to step three there isn't
one now uh if you Google step three MLS
you know the the medical license
examination there are testing out there
that you can pay money for to prepare
you for this test um but there isn't a
separate test there hasn't been a
separate test since Florida 45 50 years
ago um the other thing I did other than
operate and educate is I spent 17 years
until 2019 as a member of the New
Hampshire Board of Medicine in various
capacity member of the board member of
the uh medical uh sub committee that
doesn't exist as of this summer and as a
physician investigator uh Dr Conway will
comment on that too but if this goes
ahead and you have Deputy Physicians out
there with collaborative supervising
people there's going to be some mistakes
out there and those mistakes come to the
Board of Medicine either as complaints
or lawsuits so the ultimate
responsibility of making sure this is to
the public is in the hands of the oplc
which you know about as well as the
Board of Medicine
and um you've got to get the you've got
to get the Board of Medicine
particularly the Physicians of the Board
of Medicine to sign on to this too
because when bad things happen it comes
to that board and that board has to
figure out what to do and I don't think
they're interested in being a de facto
Residency program nor should the state
of New
Hampshire um so that's it um any
questions yes sir representative
vanti go ahead
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking uh my question I have very
specific question in terms of when a
medical student gets a
residency uh outside of where they went
to medical school very common very
common more common than not more yes can
have you know or in your experience do
they stay back in the state that they
did their
residency uh because they have a
choice or do they go
elsewhere so um there's this thing
called a match which hasn't brought up
which is a computer it wasn't
computerized but existed in my day so
you you want to go somewhere and you
don't know where that place is going to
take you
um I know in my case I trained in Boston
I did my residency in Boston and I
stayed in New England eventually uh you
tend to hover near where you train uh
training programs traditionally have
often when they finish a residency tried
to get their best and brightest and keep
them there as future faculty that's a
small number um in Primary
Care uh where I trained at Dartmouth I
trained initially at Dartmouth and then
in Boston um particularly this Residency
program that's been around 25 years the
emphasis has been the key people here
and their track Rec track record is true
um conquered Hospital currently has I
think somewhere around close to 30
doctors in primary care who all trained
in their own Residency program there
were three members who trained in their
Residency program who've been president
of the New Hampshire Medical Society so
they didn't leave New Hampshire they
didn't go up to the North Country which
is really what we want to do here I
think but if you train them in the North
Country they may stay there and I think
that's the solution to this problem um
you know medical schools have actually
expanded to understand why there's 5,000
people who haven't matched it's because
there's more medical schools graduating
people and it hasn't kept up with the
number of residency slots resident slots
are very dependent on funding uh from
the federal government medical schools
they get federal government through
research grants and so forth but
Medicare and Medicaid payments to
hospitals to train residents is
significantly higher if you're training
critical number of residents typically
20 or more
so if you
I think we could increase the number of
doctors training in the country if there
was more Federal funding for it or
interest in getting more Federal funding
going that to me is also a solution in
addition to creating more residencies
which is what we need to do but you've
got to have Federal support which is
usually connected to a hospital so most
residents train in a hospital even
Family Practice residents at conqur
spend almost half their time in conqur
hospital other than an
office okay represent any other
questions thank thank you m I'm sorry I
went so long one more question doctor
question so uh in typical residency the
uh the resident physician is is learning
is practicing and so forth in the in the
course of that thing as working with
patients and and how is that build how's
that build yeah um it's build entirely
not the work the resident does he gets a
salary but it isn't dependent on how
much work he does right those people
supervising him uh the we call typical
word is not collaborator but attending
and there's a lot of them in an academic
center they're the ones submitting the
bills of the work that gets done because
they've signed off kind of like the farm
they are totally responsible and during
that time at the for when you get a a
resident in New Hampshire gets a New
Hampshire license but it's a special
resident license right has a little r
next to it um whenever they make a
mistake or a problem and it comes to the
Board of Medicine we don't go after that
Resident we'll we'll interview the
resident we'll find out about the
resident we go after the attending sure
and that's kind of the responsible part
and I would hope the collaborators in
this this Deputy plan understand that
because I think that's how the Board of
Medicine would look at it okay huge
responsibility that's why I ended this
discussion about responsibility at the
Board of Medicine and the legislature
right thank you very
much thank you very much David
Conway thank you madam chairman and
other members of the committee
um Talk the bring it closer is that
better yes much thank you um I brought
or I sent testimony to you
electronically which you should have I
also brought copies of it with me today
which I distributed and I'll apologize
for the fact that page three is really
page two
of all right we'll we'll approximate
that one
um I am a semi- I am a retired
OBGYN um I practiced when I finished my
residency I practiced in a group
practice in Portland Main
from there I went to a rural area of
Pennsylvania which was underserved so I
know a little bit about Staffing
underserved communities um and I was
there for about eight years before I
moved to conquered in
2001 and I was on the staff at the uh
residency here in conquer I worked with
residents I worked with medical students
I know what that's about um I know how
um medical school graduates uh end up
with residency positions I'd like to
correct a couple of things that
representative um cot Cole I'm sorry
said that um as far as the number of
residency positions in
2023 there were
4,375 positions um uh total of those uh
only
2,685 were not filled in the first round
of the match which has been describe to
you um one of the alternatives to um
medical school graduates who don't match
is What's called the um supplemental
offer and acceptance program where they
go into another list which is
distributed to residencies that don't
fill um and of those only 227 were
ultimately unmatched so you're talking
about only
227 medical school graduates
that ultimately did not have a residency
position after they
graduated one other correction I'd like
to make is somebody who graduates from
medical school is a
doctor
period that doctor cannot practice
cannot be licensed until they have
received some kind of
training um I testified against the
earlier um uh bills in 2018 and 2019 and
the only thing that's changed in this
bill is the title it's a deputy
physician instead of an assistant
physician instead of a graduate
physician that my biggest objection has
been the lack of
supervision uh of the Deputy physician
that the only thing that's required
there are two things that are required
that in the initial month the deputy
physician or the collaborating physician
must be in close proximity in the same
in the same office to be available to
the deputy
physician after
that the deputy physician has to submit
um
10% of his records every two weeks for
the uh collaborating physician to uh
review that's retrospective
care that's the deputy physician is
making decisions about care but it's not
being reviewed by The collaborating
Physician for two weeks so who knows if
he's making the right
decisions
um I don't have a whole lot more I was I
had this I was not going to read the
testimony I gave to you it tends to get
tiresome after a while um one thing that
uh this bill provides for is a track to
getting a full medical license without
ever having done a
residency that I will tell you that
residencies in the first year here with
this residency
um every single patient that the
resident saw had to be reviewed that day
before the patient left to make sure
that care was appropriate that the uh
diagnosis the residents came up with was
accurate that's not happening
with a deputy
physician it's just not
happening
um another correction as far as uh other
uh Deputy uh physician programs around
the country as of uh 2023 uh Missouri
was the first one that was established
in 2014 there are currently uh eight um
I don't have the list here um but there
are eight other programs um and the
intent of those programs is to uh not
move towards full lure after X number of
years but to move towards actually doing
a residency where they had uh supervised
training
um what this bill is trying to do is to
return uh us to the apprenticeship
program which was done away with uh in
the late
1800s um and
the outcome of that has been improved
care where there was very organized uh
specific training provided to those
Physicians
um uh representative Cole talked about
shadowing physicians in residency
shadowing means you follow around and
you watch what a physician is doing not
the case as a resident that's what you
do as a medical student but as a
resident you're the first person who is
seeing that patient to make some kind of
decision some kind of diagnosis which
you then take to the preceptor of the
day the person who you have to check out
your impressions before that patient
goes home I don't have a whole lot more
to say um that's not in the testimony
that I submitted uh but I'd be glad to
take any questions thank you are there
questions thank you very much for your
testimony
Douglas a if it wasn't clear I'm opposed
to this Bill thank you Doctor it was
quite
clear Douglas ster how oplc I should
only take about a minute of your time uh
I was looking at the language and it
looks like some of the language as
proposed is in conflict with RSA 310 and
just sort of the roles and
responsibilities so if the committee or
we if if the committee should decide to
move forward with this bill I'm just
offering my services uh so we could
Amendment and make those two sort of
aign okay thank you very much for that
we'll we'll let the subcommittee know
that you can help questions all
right thank you very much well if it's
going to be amended it's going to sub
committee all right all right is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
House Bill
sure this will be quick um it's in my
written testimony as far as why don't uh
medical school graduates match and it's
um for a variety of reasons um
there probably were
about seven reasons anywhere from having
low scores on the uh USM League exams
during residency being not competitive
at their first choice of uh residency
lack of appropriate backup or an
alternative plan not failure to follow
guidance from The Faculty adviser or
Dean's office poor interviewing or
interpersonal skills did not rank enough
programs or failed uh the USMLE exam so
um that's the pool of people you're
looking at thank you that pretty clear
all
right no one else is here on this I'll
close the hearing and open the hearing
on House Bill
1394 and call Representative
McGee
well thank you Madame chair Maguire um
good to be with you good to see you all
again I'm representative cat McGee and
I'm from Hillsboro 35 which is Hollis
um I'm here to present HB 394 which is a
bill that may be familiar to all of
you um this bill came to us um its first
time four iterations ago when I was um
approached by a constituent of mine who
is a music therapist in Hollis about the
issue of having certification under
professional lure in New
Hampshire and there have been subsequent
hearings I went and looked up the
history the original bill was hb1 1286
uh which passed the house but then was
laid on the table in the senate in June
of
2020 um it was removed from the table in
September of 2020 and it and then there
was HB 209 which was a split vote on
this committee and went to
itl um and then HB 532 this last year
year of this session um there was work
and amendments on the larger Bill and
all appeared to be a go and then it died
on June 27th without all the signatures
um after a committee of conference so
there was a question whether we wanted
to um present the bill again but in
speaking again with the music therapists
who've been participating in this
process all along they nothing has
changed for them and I thought maybe
what would be helpful is to sort of
present to you the Dilemma that they are
confronting in their profession so I
went and looked up the music therapy
board certification website has some
information about um you know where the
profession is at with uh Statewide
certifications and also why they why
they're needed so um I just offer for
you today this very brief
blurb which is that a national
certification is not enough in Most
states and this is the result of a
policy shift over the past 10 to 15
years as the federal government has
moved away from regulation or have been
deregulating and they've allocated that
regul regulatory control to the state
level so uh in many uh in addition many
existing state regulations require that
education and health care providers hold
a state license so that shifting
landscape is the reason that they were
brought forward to say we you know we
really would like you to consider giving
us the ability to be part of the Allied
Health Care under the state state
certification and
lure so as a result many current and
potential clients are having difficulty
accessing Music Therapy
Services um within educational and
healthc Care Facilities which is where
most of the Consulting work is provided
so that's sort of an access point um and
then of course insurers are don't have
them listed in their drop- down menus
for folks to choose in terms of a
specific Allied therapy and the
inability for people to choose um them
from that list also prohibits them from
being reimbursed under insurance so
there are you know multiple issues in
terms of them using their professional
licenses here in the state of New
Hampshire
um so that's a little bit about the
history and then on the bill itself uh
as you all know in last year's session
um there were some changes to the
oplc um statute and uh some stuff was
moved around so uh OS had a good time
when I resubmitted the most recent
amendment to them for reworking and they
have updated uh the bill that you have
in front of you so that it is current
with the oplc statute as it stands today
and
basically it's giving um giving the um
the format to adding them into Allied
health professionals that they would
require in statute and um has all of the
changes that have been worked on and
considered over the several years that
they've been attempting to do this so
there are definitions here as to what
music therapy entails What It Is What It
Isn't that it doesn't um it doesn't uh
infringe in any other type of therapy
that may be similar I know the um audio
speech therapy folks had some concerns
around language they brought in language
that had been used in other states um
and there are currently about 36% of the
states so 18 states right now uh have
music uh certified music therapy as an
Allied Health in the state so we're just
um trying to help these folks uh get
where they need to be and for those of
you I don't know how long all of you
have been on the committee I know some
of you have been here the whole time um
one of the things that was very
interesting to me because I knew very
little about music therapy when I
started this road with this
constituent um in the very first hearing
she brought a former
patient that she had worked with and he
is now an adult he was a child when she
met him he was um born blind and he is
now um an inspirational speaker and he
was very inspirational the day that he
came to the hearing but what was amazing
was that um his parents were they had a
lot of difficulty trying to figure out
how to reach him so I liken it to sort
of The Miracle Worker right you have to
to fix the you have to figure out the
right key in order to reach certain
people and um and once you do bridge
that Gap and do figure out how to reach
those people um then you can have the
kind of success that he had in his life
and he came in to the hearing to give
this committee that information and I
was really impressed I didn't know he
was coming um and I didn't of course
know him but um I think since that time
the therapists them eles have come in on
several occasions both for work sessions
and also um to provide the committee
with additional
information I think they're all sort of
working today and so uh when we talked
about them coming it was in the midst of
the snowstorm and I think they are very
hopeful that you know there has been
there have been tears uh when the bill
hasn't gone through before but I think
they're also um they're reluctant to
Hope at this point but I am here to
represent them and ask that you continue
to um give this your due consideration
because I understand that there um may
be sentiments against having lots of
certifications or so many certifications
or adding to
certifications but this is a legitimate
form of therapy and um and we have you
know I have talked to people who have
benefited from it so that's how I've
come to that
conclusion and I think that if we are
not allowing them to to participate with
other forms of
therapy um then we are
um I think it's we're unduly picking
those who can participate in insurance
and those who can't so um so I don't
have any more information about the
profession itself and and I think you
have probably heard a significant amount
of testimony on that on this committee
so if I can be of any assistance
answering any questions I will do my
best to do that and that'll just
conclude my testimony okay are there
questions yes representative man prudy
I'm sorry madam
chair uh being a speech pathologist in
my past life and music therapy was a
huge Avenue for people with aasia one
very well-known case is the
congresswoman Gabby gford her regaining
of speech was is through music therapy
and there are several uh instances where
I've used that for people with Autism to
break through for
communication and this is only with
people who are diagnosed
with speech or communication disorder
earlier but music therapy can be very
beneficial for hum other situations who
are trained so have you had opportunity
to get those and the music therapists
they're not just music teachers have you
got input from music therapist
particularly on other than speech and
communication disorder group that could
benefit like one was the blind or was
the other ones yeah I think
um I think the overlap between speech
therapy and and music therapy has to do
with communication issues in children
and adults and I think most people
understand that music has a unique space
in terms of how people connect to music
and in some cases they connect to music
and and little else um but again I'm I'm
not an expert I'm not I didn't know that
you were in speech therapy so that's
interesting um I do know that um it is a
therapy that in certain instances is
unique in terms of how it can help
someone um overcome any any number of
disabilities educational disabilities
learning disabilities that kind of thing
so um you're right I think a lot of
people conflate just being able to play
music or participate in music and I
think part of that language is in the
bill stating what music therapists do
how they collaborate how they determine
um appropriate courses of care and they
document goals and they achieve those
goals through the therapy so like any
other therapy um
so that's about all I can
say all right
um I think that's it y
okay representative Roy oh excuse me
representative
schmith thank you mam pure uh good
afternoon
present so th this bill that you're
presenting to us today is the identical
bill that has passed this Committee in
the most recent
iteration based on the the
uh um the collaboration with the speech
pathologists and and uh the the
agreement they the the
two uh practices came to to resolve the
issue that did hang us up
three or four years ago right yes so
this version is the one that was was
adopted by the house in the last go
round correct yes latest and greatest
all the bells and whistles and also
updated again for the oplc changes um
because I I went back and forth with uh
Patrick Conroy I believe it is in OS he
was very helpful in saying well this the
section's gone so you can't refer to
that so you know he so he updated it so
that it is it is accurate and it
contains all of the work group product
that uh this committee brought to the
bill um in in its last iterations um
followup thank followup so so as you
know I have a I think she's not
technically a constituent of mine in do
because um she lives in the South End
and I represent the central area but um
Marissa is her first name I'm sure
you've spoken with her many times do you
know whether she's watching the hearing
again today I would imagine she is if
she's able okay well perhaps we'll see
that and I believe representative Roy
spoke with her this morning well she was
cheering us on he'll speak to to that I
I spoke with her relatively recently and
she's still very hopeful I believe so I
guess representative Roy will tell us
thank you very much for your advocacy
and you can count on me to be voting yes
on this Bill thank you thank you you're
welcome thank you representative McGee
thank you representative Roy
good afternoon thank you representative
Terry Roy Rockingham District 31 um I'm
here as a co-sponsor today of this
bill as uh the previous speaker told you
I know this has been here several
several times
um uh like all of you I wear a couple
hats around here here one of them is the
chairman of the veterans interest caucus
and my interest in this bill was laser
focused on Veterans um and what it can
do for veterans when I first heard about
music therapy I also maybe like many of
you thought it was some kind of strange
snake oil thing um when I heard music
therapy what the heck is that so I did
my research on it the Department of
Defense and particularly the US Army has
been using m music therapy since
1945 it's a well-established thing um
they sent out a technical bulletin in
1945 on the
programming uh program for the use of
reconditioning among service members
cesing in the Army
hospitals since 2000 um specifically
around 2005 the VA has doubled the
number of Music therapists that work at
the
VA um so the Veterans Administration
takes this therapy very seriously and
they use it a lot the problem our
constituents have in New Hampshire is
that although we have a medical center
in Manchester it's not what's called in
the VA Parliament a full service medical
so they don't have all the type of
things that you might find at a bigger
VA hospital to include music therapists
so veterans in New Hampshire who may
benefit from this have to seek what's
called Community Care and to do that
they have to use a licensed music
therapist which we do not have in New
Hampshire our veterans really can use
this and I like many of you am not a fan
of just handing out licenses for
everything that might possibly want or
have a license but this is an
established um well researched um form
of care for people that is not
experimental it it's been used for many
many decades and I feel that it
justifies ler so that these people can
do this and provide this service for our
veterans and get paid to do it with
regard to what music therapy does I'm
just going to read something real quick
and it'll conclude my
testimony music therapy has been proven
to help with a whole He of health
problems it can assist with physical
rehabilitation help people learn to
speak again improve communication skills
and help people manage negative emotions
and combat depression anxiety all of
these things that might benefit veterans
this is I'm reading from a VA thing when
you listen to music your ear collects
sound waves and and funnels them to your
inner ear where they are converted to
electrical signals those electrical
signals then travel through your brain
stimulating different parts of your
brain to cause different reactions music
stimulates the parts of your brain
associated with memory emotion vocal
imitation and movement among other
things as a result music can affect the
functioning of those parts of the brain
on the body meaning that can have a real
physiological effects since music
stimulates the cerebrum which is
associated with memory it can also help
your memory sharp keep it sharp which
may be useful for veterans struggling
with brain injuries or PTSD induced
Amnesia while music stimulates the lyic
system which is responsible for
emotional responses it has also been
shown to help suppress negative emotions
while elevating positive ones this can
be incredibly useful in modulating
feelings of depression and
anxiety the physical and cognitive
benefits of music therapy are also
manifold and always growing since music
affects the parts of the brain
responsible for the movement and
communication it can assist with
physical or speech
Rehabilitation human beings have an
Impulse to move with rhythms and when
you pair listening to music with
practicing a specific movement over and
over like clapping or taking a step that
movement can get more fluid and become
ingrained in your muscle memory music
therapists have been using this method
to help chair-bound or bedbound veterans
get back on their feet for years it is
certainly useful for wounded
veterans keeping in mind we're still
fighting a uh an epidemic of 22 veteran
suicides A Day in the United States I
would hope that the committee would take
that into account and look at the
possibility of using this to help our
veterans in Hampshire gain further
access to that and I'm willing to take
any questions thank you for your time
thank you are there
questions yes thank you I'm seeing as
someone else give us someone else a
chance first representative man
py thank you madam chair so um the
Jamaica plane or Roxberry VA Center has
a very well established music therap MIT
it's called music internation therapy
have you been able to get that
information very well formed this was
1945 they've done a lot of study with
the
veterans that has given a very credible
thing with yeah they they use it down
there at the Jamaica plane one um
unfortunately that's quite a hike for a
lot of our veterans and they just they
can't get down there and there are a lot
of people in in places up here where
they could get it if we could just get
them licensed thank representative
Gart I just thought of something is
there a remote
option um sometimes sometimes not it
depends on the therapy what what they're
being treated for it's not always
something you could do just over the
Internet because of the the actual
vibrations you feel from the music even
if you're using it to walk and things
like that to pick up motor skills um
perhaps I'm not really sure so I don't
want to speculate but everything I've
seen is it's been in person and there's
also the issue of Licensing cross state
lines and billing and things like that
thank you
okay all right thank you very much
representative Roy thank you chairwoman
thank you members of the
committee dou s
hat
good afternoon Douglas Sout general
counsel oplc my testimony is the same as
last time I found a couple of uh
discrepancies between the language as
proposed and the language in 310 and I'm
just offering my services to clean that
up should the committee decide to move
forward okay so we should not move it
forward without cleaning up the language
all right any other questions
comments thank you
for should we not
consider should we not consider the
perfected Bill and have the changes that
council aout is uh referring to here in
his remarks shouldn't we have that
done yes please if you could send us
where the issues are we would appreciate
that email
works I can do that
yes
all
right does anyone else wish to testify
on House Bill
1394 okay I don't see anybody so I'll
close the public
hearing and I will see you all
tomorrow Mr Vice chairman uh believe we
we have a subcommittee meeting tomorrow
morning at
9:00 very good thank you okay guys going
to
seea